welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford School of
Medicine my guest today is Dr K Tai Dr K
Tai is a professor of neuroscience at
the sulk Institute for biological
studies she did her training at MIT and
at Stanford and is currently an
investigator with the Howard Hughes
Medical Institute which is a highly
curated group of individuals who are
incentivized to do highrisk high reward
work and Pioneer new areas of biological
study throughout her career Dr Kai has
made fundamental breakthroughs into our
understanding of the brain including
demonstrating that a brain area called
the amydala which most people associate
with fear and threat detection is
actually involved in reinforcement of
behaviors and experiences that are
positive and involve reward her current
work focuses on various aspects of
social interaction including what
happens when we feel lonely or isolated
indeed today K Tai will tell us about
her discovery of so-called loneliness
neurons neurons that give us that sense
that we are not being fulfilled from our
social interactions she also describes a
phenomenon she discovered called social
homeostasis which is our sense that we
are experiencing enough not enough or
just enough social interaction
irrespective of whether or not we are an
introvert or an extrovert we also talk
about social hierarchies and social rank
how people and animals tear out into
so-called alphas and betas subordinates
and dominants Etc in all sorts of social
interactions I think everyone will find
that discussion especially interesting
and we talk about the role of social
media and online interactions and why
despite extensive interaction with many
many individuals those social media and
online interactions can often leave us
feeling deprived in specific ways we
talk about the neurochemical the neural
circuit and some of the hormonal aspects
of social interactions it's a discussion
that by the end will have you thinking
far more deeply about what is a social
interaction and why certain social
interactions leave us feeling so good
others feeling sort of meh and why other
social interactions or lack of social
interactions can often leave us feeling
quite depleted even depressed it's a
conversation Central to mental illness
and the understanding of things like
like depression and anxiety PTSD and
isolation and it's a conversation
Central to mental health and in order to
build healthy social interactions before
we begin I'd like to emphasize that this
podcast is separate from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to Consumer information about
science and science related tools to the
general public in keeping with that
theme I'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast our first sponsor is
eight sleep eight sleep makes Smart
mattress covers with cooling Heating and
sleep tracking capacity I've spoken many
times before on this other podcast about
the fact that sleep is the foundation of
mental health physical health and
performance now one of the key aspects
to getting a great night's sleep is to
control the temperature of your sleeping
environment and that's because in order
to fall and stay deeply asleep your body
temperature actually has to drop by
about 1 to 3° and in order to wake up in
the morning feeling refreshed your body
temperature actually has to increase by
about 1 to three degrees eight sleep
makes it extremely easy to control the
temperature of your sleeping environment
at the beginning middle and throughout
the night and when you wake up in the
morning I've been sleeping on an eight
Sleep mattress cover for nearly 3 years
now and it has dramatically improved my
sleep if you'd like to try eightsleep
you can go to 8sleep.com
huberman to save $150 off their pod3
cover eights sleep currently ships to
the USA Canada UK select countries in
the EU and Australia again that's
8sleep.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by levels levels is a program that
lets you you see how different foods and
different activities and your sleep
patterns impact your health by giving
you real-time feedback on your diet
using a continuous glucose monitor now
blood glucose sometimes referred to as
blood sugar has an immediate and
long-term impact on your energy levels
and your overall health one of the best
ways to maintain focus and energy
throughout your day as well as to keep
your so-called metabolic Health in best
order is to make sure that your blood
glucose never spikes too much nor does
it get too low
with levels you can monitor how
different foods and food combinations
impact your blood glucose levels on a
momentto moment basis I've been using
levels for some time now and it's really
helped me understand which foods and
food combinations exercise schedules and
sleep schedules are optimal for my blood
glucose levels and how that translates
to energy levels and other metrics of
Health if you're interested in learning
more about levels and trying a
continuous glucose monitor you can go to
levels. l/h huberman levels has just
launched a a new CGM sensor that is
smaller and has even better tracking
than before right now they're also
offering two free months of membership
again that's levels. linkli nk/ huberman
to try the new sensor and two free
months of membership today's episode is
also brought To Us by element element is
an electrolyte drink that has everything
you need and nothing you don't that
means zero sugar and the appropriate
ratios of the electrolyt sodium
magnesium and potassium and that correct
ratio of electrolytes is extremely
important because every cell in your
body but especially your nerve cells
your neurons relies on electrolytes in
order to function properly so when
you're well hydrated and your hydration
also includes the appropriate ratios of
electrolytes your mental functioning and
your physical functioning is improved I
drink one packet of element dissolved in
about 16 to 32 ounces of water when I
wake up in the morning as well as while
I exercise and if I've sweat a lot
during that exercise I often will drink
a third element packet dissolved in
about 32 ounces of water after I
exercise element comes in a variety of
different flavors personally I like all
the fruit flavors so raspberry and
watermelon are my favorite I also like
the Citrus flavored one frankly I can't
really pick just one of the fruit
flavors I like them all so much and it
also comes in chocolate and chocolate
mint flavors which I find are best in
the winter months because of course you
don't just need hydration on hot days
and in the summer and spring months but
also in the winter when the temperatures
are cold and the environment tends to be
dry if you'd like to try element you can
go to drink element spelled lnt.com
huberman to try a free sample pack again
that's drink element.com
huberman and now for my conversation
with Dr K Tai Dr K Tai welcome Andy
huberman what a treat folks are going to
hear you call me Andy and wonder if my
name is Andy I always know who I'm
speaking to according to whether or not
they call me Andrew which is my family
and people that I know after a certain
period of my life Drew which are people
that know me through my very brief and
non- illustrious career in boxing
and Andy which are people that met me as
I was coming up through science uh let's
just put it this way there was another
Andrew we did a coin flip and I lost so
Andy is fine Andrew is fine whatever
makes you comfortable what's important
today is not how anyone refers to me but
rather the discussion about your work
which is spectacular I've known you a
long time and I've been following your
career and it's just been amazing and
wonderful to see the contributions
you've made to science and also to the
culture of science so we're going to
talk about both of those things to kick
things off let's talk about a brain
structure that most people I think have
heard of but that is badly misunderstood
and that's the amydala most people hear
amydala and they think oh fear that's
what the amydala is all about but you
know
and I'm hoping you'll educate us on the
fact that that the amydala is actually
far more complex than that and far more
interesting than that so when you hear
the word amydala where does your mind go
I agree that a lot of the the bandwidth
on the amydala has been occupied by fear
studies but we've known actually for
really long time that the amydala is
important for all sorts of emotional
processing since clu and beuty
performed lesions on on monkeys and
found that monkeys would then have flat
affective responses to all sorts of
different stimuli poop food inanimate
object whatever it was just nothing no
emotion no emotional response no
motivational significance however you
want to phrase it to things that usually
would make you either you know disgusted
or excited or neutral and so um I think
that that knowledge about the amydala
was there from the beginning it's not
something I came up with um but then
it's interesting it's almost a it's a
meta statement or meta observation about
how scientific research progresses
sometimes you make a lot of progress in
one particular vein because it's easy to
press forward there but it's important
to also think about all the other parts
and filling in the space in between to
make sure you haven't missed anything so
the narrative about the amigdala became
about fear and and I think also just
when we think about
survival when you are an animal in the
natural world especially if you're a
prey animal which is the majority you
know that's a lot of animals um then you
need to prioritize escaping a predator
it's immediate threat on your survival
versus rewards set mating drinking water
getting food these things can be done
later escaping this Predator is
Paramount and so there should be some
natural a symmetry in how we process
emotion at Baseline and so that's
something that we've looked into a lot
as well but um I think the the big
picture discovery that um my team has
contributed to our understanding of the
amigdala is that it represents a fork in
the road uh for processing emotional
veence and thinking about all these old
psychological theories about how do you
emotionally evaluate the world around
you what's what's the what's the chain
of events is there chain of events
what's happening in a certain order um
versus what's happening in parallel for
example one model is you know there's
all this information that comes in and
then we have to filter out what's
important um what's going to be
something I need to pay attention to
versus what do I need to ignore if I'm
driving I need to pay attention to the
road this this light this pedestrian
just started walking versus you know
what it feels like for my sock to be
touching my foot not super relevant
right now or the my butt against the
seat not nothing I need to pay attention
to I need to focus on you know the
dynamic information then you have to
select you know the Second Step would be
selecting whether it's good or bad and
what you want to do with it and so that
process I think the selection of whether
you're um assigning it a positive or
negative veilance happens in the amydala
so glad you brought up this word
veilance I think it's a word that some
scientists but most of the general
public are probably not familiar with so
let's um talk about veilance um and then
I want to go back to the amydala and um
kind of explore some of its diversity of
function a little bit more so when I
hear the word veilance I think goodness
versus Badness yeah of something is that
basically basically it's been used in a
lot of different fields I think of that
you know negative and positive numbers
or or um but it's an analogy that we
take to just mean yeah net positive net
net negative and it's it's a intentional
departure from the word value um value
becomes very scalar everything's on you
know it can be in the same direction
with different magnitudes is often how
we think about value it it could be
representing both valances but um often
it's a small reward and a big reward or
small punishment and big punishment is
how experimentally we parse um value and
so veillance is just asking about um how
your brain responds to things that are
good or bad what are neurons that might
respond similarly to things that are
good and bad you know those might be
importance neurons rather than um
positive or negative veilance neurons so
yeah I I think it's a it's just a term
that that signifies that next step so
when we walk into say a novel
environment um do you think that our
amygdalas are active and really trying
to figure out whether or not an
environment a set of people or a person
is safe and really just check that box
first in order to be able to do other
things is you know is this business of
um determining veilance and the role of
the amydala in that kind of the first
gate that we have to walk through
anytime we're in a new environment for
instance you showed up here today and
you mentioned you know I think I locked
my car and um and I said you'll be fine
in this neighborhood either way and then
you walked in and presumably you were
taking in the new environment meeting
some new people um we had a little
discussion about caffeine uh a little
discussion about alcohol and presumably
because you and I know one another you
felt safe I would hope so but presumably
the amydala is always performing this
role even if we have some prior
knowledge about something just figuring
out am I safe here where are the exits
where are the entrances uh who's here
what's their story um do you think all
of that is is operating and do you think
it's always conscious or is it largely
unconscious to us
okay so there's a few different
questions there um first I want to
address the the question about novelty
and then I want to come back to this the
other issue of conscious but um the way
that amydala works is its job is is to
assign meaning to anything that could
have motivational significance and so if
it's a brand new thing we're paying
attention we're seeing if if it if it
mattered did it matter and so I think
anything that's novel even if we don't
know what it means a loud sound you've
never heard before um even if it
signifies nothing of motivational
significance the first few times that
you're presented with it you'll get an
amigdalar response so you see this in
the lab play the tone for the first time
and then there's a response that rapidly
decays when the tone doesn't end up
predicting anything that the the animal
can can detect or human is this also
true in this is true in humans um if
you're the type of person that puts your
phone on do not disturb versus has it on
vibrate and you know sometimes it's
always vibrating and it's just it
vibrates all the time whereas I put my
phone on do not disturb and so when
someone else's phone rings it's very
startling to me but they they don't even
notice because their phone that's just
the sound their phone makes it makes it
all the time so I think it has to do
with how many times you're presented
with it and it's it's a startle response
so the first few times that you are
presented with a stimulus uh the amydala
will respond and then it decays very
quickly and then only if that stimulus
predicts something important or
something rewarding or or punishing then
uh will will begin to respond again so
it's it's like you're giving everything
novel
a chance to to tell you in one trial in
single trial learning um if something's
going to happen and
so um I think a fire alarm is a great
example you know fire alarm goes off
you're
you're instantly you know you're looking
around is there anything happening even
even just people rushing out you know
there's there's this the Salient thing
that you're going to respond to and you
know if you have a lot of fire drills
then you might respond differently after
a while so I think that's the
habituation component you mentioned that
the amigdala will respond to a novel
stimulus
um and if it predicts something
interesting then other things happen
we'll talk about those um if not the
amydala stops responding and you said
something really important which is that
the amydala will respond to something
that is predicting reward or punishment
and I think most people don't realize
that in fact I think a lot of early
career neurobiologists don't realize
that that the amydala is not just
involved in fear and Punishment um so
when we talk about the amydala
presumably we're talking about the
amydala complex a bunch of other things
so is it true that there are neurons in
the amydala complex that predict reward
and others that predict fear and
Punishment yeah so um as a graduate
student I worked on a part of the
amydala called the basolateral amydala
it's still a complex Within the broader
amydala
um this brain region is cortical like in
that it's mostly glutamatergic neurons
with some gab argic neurons mixed in but
without the same structure that the
cortex has um and I studied the the
amigdala in the context of reward I
found essentially that when you induce
plasticity you get a synaptic
strengthening when you uh when animals
learn things amigdala neurons fire in
response to cues that predict rewards
and this was you coming into the context
of a field that had shown that this
happens with fear and so this became I I
remember my the very first time I gave
um a SC a presentation at a scientific
conference I was a junior graduate
student I was given a 10-minute talk at
the you know inaugural amigdala Gordon
research conference many famous
professors were
speaking and there were two talks about
the amigdala and reward and I was one of
them and the response to the talk was
just how is this possible how can how
can the amydala how can how can you get
the same readout for reward and fear and
really it came to be there's two two
possibilities I there's more
possibilities but the main two
possibilities are number one that the
amydala wasn't specific for fear at all
it just responds to anything important
if it's important it responds period the
other possibility is that the amydala is
sending has different neurons that
respond to positive and negative
predictive stimuli and sends this
information to different Downstream
targets to respond differently obviously
I respond differently to a reward I walk
towards it I I consume it a punishment
I'm avoiding it and so clearly the
behaviors are diametrically opposed and
so to me it seemed very possible at
least that that there was a Divergence
point and maybe this could be it and so
we just did some very simple experiments
when I first started my lab to trace the
projection targets of amydala neurons
and record and so everything's all mixed
up together so it's not obvious that
they would that that this would be a
fork in the road but when you look at
them you do see that there are
projections that come from the amigdala
that are predominantly encoding either
reward or fear and there's many
different projections and um you know
this is just the beginning but this was
a time when it
a novel concept to even think that
neurons from one region could have
completely different functions going to
different Downstream targets which now
seems totally obvious um and it there's
hundreds and hundreds of papers showing
it now but at the time it was difficult
to get this work published because
that's just not how people thought
about information moving through the
brain I guess well I think um first of
all such important work and so wonderful
to be uh uh early in the the phase of
recasting how the brain works which is
what you did um I think most people in
the general public still think amydala
fear and uh clearly it's able to Signal
reward and Punishment as you discovered
and are now pointing out um I'm curious
does the amydala have a direct line to
some of the organs of the body that can
change our bodily activation state heart
rate breathing rate um muscle tension
because I think most of us experience
fear and reward as both in our head in
our brains but also of the body great
question great question so um I'll tell
you the clues that lead me to my current
working model which may you know is not
necessarily the final word but I would
say that I think the amydala complex as
we're discussing it these 13 subnuclei
that reside you know in the temporal
lobe
they are important for assigning
importance but they're not important for
producing the actual autonomic arousal
that we associate with Panic or fear the
reason I say this is there's a famous
case study patient SM who have has
bilateral damage to her amyd and um in
you know no responses to emotional faces
no responses to fearful stimuli um but
if you
if capable of having the Panic response
due to low to to Suffocation associated
with it with Suffocation and so there's
still the ability to produce that panic
and arousal response um it's just not
the cognitive evaluation of it I think
that's what we think the amydala is
doing is assigning that it it does
receive information from the rest of the
body um there are for example gin
receptors in the amydala things that can
sense hunger and um we've done
some some work looking at this kind of
inspired by I'm not sure if this you're
familiar with this study um it's a
controversial study Dan zigger 2011 but
where the Supreme Court judges they they
looked at Supreme Court Judge rulings on
on parole decisions um across the day
relative to meal breaks and you can see
right after it's like it's like
breakfast you know 90% everybody's
getting for everybody's getting out yeah
and then it just drops till 10% then
there's lunch then we're back to 80% and
then it just precipitously drops to
single digits again so the judges are
changing the leniency of their rulings
depending on how wellfed they are you
know there there are counterarguments to
this but that is strongly what the data
suggests you know it is not a controlled
study it is just a striking correlation
um but it's the it's it's not a
completely novel concept the hangry
phenomenon I'm sure I don't know
everybody's different I certainly
experience it um but we we think that
when you are getting strong signals from
the body for example you know I think I
think the amdal is going to be able to
detect a lot of different homeostatic
inputs even though we haven't we don't
have evidence for that yet but for
specifically energy balance when you're
hungry um your amydala can detect it
perhaps through grin receptors or other
other you know mechanisms um and then
what we see is that in that food deprive
after one day of food dep deprivation
for mice
um you can see this shift in the balance
between the positive veilance um
encoding projection neurons and the
negative veence en coding projection
neurons and a at
Baseline fear trumps all the negative
projection neurons you know can silence
the reward projection ones which makes
sense if I need to run away from this
Predator you know I can't I can't worry
about eating this food right now but if
I'm in a near starvation like state
which for my they have very high
metabolism so one day without food is a
really big deal um they only last a few
days so um at this point they are
kicking into survival mode where
actually getting food becomes the the
greater need and you'll see animals you
know hunting in ways they normally
wouldn't hunt when when they're really
desperate and so this mode of of food
deprivation shifts things so that the
reward um pathway actually has stronger
power to to influence and silence the uh
fear pathway than before wow the brain
is so smart it really is it can take
what we normally think of as a priority
list fear and staying safe is more
important than food reward and then if
food and acquiring food is critical to
survival it can invert all that is what
you're saying exactly amazing and it
happens you know in a day it seems
reversible so that's something that
we're looking at right now and thinking
about um um how specific is this this to
food is this true for lots of different
things what about exercise other other
stressors that are you know potentially
more positive the amydala is able to
detect a lot of different signals from
the environment and we're not sure how
all of that gets in there um so I think
one of the the detection of the
environment has been you know really
well worked out in terms of our basic
sensory modalities but think about the
things that really affect your emotions
day-to- day at least for me as a human
in this Society the things that affect
my emotions mostly today are almost
entirely social interactions very subtle
ones ones that don't seem to threaten my
life or safety you know very small
subtle um social interactions are are
what you know have the greatest bearing
I think on um my emotional evaluation
and my emotional bandwidth and what is
that how do we detect that how do we
assemble this information apply all the
Nuance you know put on the onion layers
of social programming to come out with
whatever you know I interpret this
gesture to mean it's it's pretty
incredible and so that's kind of where
uh my research program has has been
sliding such a interesting area let's
drill into it a bit um and to put it in
context maybe um we talk about social
media um so on social media um whether
or not it's Instagram or X those are
seem to be the two major platforms I'm
not on Tik Tok
um people say stuff sometimes they say
positive things sometimes they see say
negative things sometimes they say
things that are sort of neutral um so it
seems to me that nowadays if one is on
these social media platforms that we are
um we've sort of crowdsourced
this phenomenon of social interaction in
a way that we hadn't before because I I
grew up prior to the Advent of social
media and I could bring my physical body
into certain environments and not others
even at high school I could hang out we
had an area called the Batcave where you
know skateboarders and some other at
that time Misfits hung out with the quad
where the cool kids hung out um Etc you
could you could pick your Niche okay
social media is not like that you can
pick followers they can pick you Etc but
I think since most people have social
media nowadays seems or on there in some
ways that we've placed ourselves in the
center of an arena which we have a ton
of incoming input we all most of us have
amigdalas two of them amydala you
pointed out one on each side of the
brain and presumably we're on these
platforms to receive positive feedback
and avoid negative feedback
however there does seem to be a cohort
of people who seem to like the friction
of com combat or kind of let's just call
it high friction interactions or
moderate friction interactions they like
to argue they like to parse ideas it's
not all bad necessarily um so have you
ever looked at social media in your in
your own mind looked at social media
through the lens of of amydala filtering
or through the lens of of neural circuit
filtering and kind of wondered um what's
going on there that someone with without
your in-depth knowledge of these brain
circuitries would not think to uh look
at that landscape through or maybe we
could just do that now as a as as a kind
of play experiment I like that um so I a
lot of people ask me about social media
from the context of is this of is this
social contact meaningful is this
positive does this count does this help
you not feel lonely um and of course I
don't know the answer we haven't done
that particular study yet and I don't I
don't know of that specific study having
been performed but my prediction um is
that it's not going to do much because I
I believe that a key component of what I
would consider social contact heavily
depends on having some interbrain
synchron some interaction in in that is
synchronous and I think with social
media sometimes there can be an engaging
dialogue that plays out in near real
time but generally speaking it's
asynchronous you're looking at things
that are happened that you're not a part
of you're excluded from all these things
they happened in Australia yesterday and
I'm on there saying cool love it and
then the person's already asleep yes
exactly that's by asynchronous
asynchronous like that we're not
experiencing things at the same time
it's not a shared experience you know
that in in terms of that having that
Bond necessarily and so I've never
actually been asked about how the
amydala processes social media um I
guess I think what happens is you know
the amydala is just responding to
stimuli sending up bottom up signals you
know it's a caricature of of um bottom
up and top down processing let's give an
example that I'm I'm walking down the
street and all of a sudden I hear like a
really ferocious dog barking at me all
going crazy and then I get super scared
and then I realize okay there's a fence
so the amydala detect you know heard the
dog barking hey there's a dog barking
and you know I'm freaking out then my
prefrontal cortex realizes there the F
it looks very sturdy this fence looks
stable and then I'm relaxing and I'm
resuming my walking normally you know I
think that's sort of the dance that our
brain is doing when we have top down and
bottom up uh information then we're
trying to stay focused so for me I think
when I'm on social media there's so many
stimuli that that are evoking responses
and um to be completely transparent and
I know this is not something that
everybody else does or can do is
necessarily what's best for them but I
work very hard to control input from the
top down um in terms of I really really
limit the amount I I basically don't
check email or go on social media I
would say I'm on social media or email
less than one hour per week basically
perek per week oh I have to say to that
is congratulations we'll talk about
social media again in a second but as a
fellow Professor email once a week I've
heard of people scheduling their times
for email responses but once a week that
is awesome I have have people who help
me get through it and filter out what's
important but otherwise I just whenever
I do my own email I say yes to all these
things then I make all these plans and
then I'm and then I'm have too many
trips and I'm responding fra fragmented
fragmented and it's just you know
overcommit and I think um I know my
limits sometimes it's difficult ult for
me to be in my amydala mode responding
to stimuli and yet letting my prefrontal
cortex do its thing so I've set some
very heavy prefrontal cortically
selected limits of the input I put in so
that my brain can function and be clear
I can't be creative I can't have
epiphanies if there's all this clutter
of like writing this person back and
blah blah blah blah blah tweet tweet
it's just you know trash out wipe
squeegee squeegee the brain down so that
we can actually grow something beautiful
and new
well and I want to re-emphasize what I
said in my introduction which is that I
mean you are oh so productive and when I
say productive I don't just mean
productive like plug-and chug you you
the work you've done is incredibly
creative you transformed our
understanding of what this famous
structure the amydala actually does I
mean you've made so many important
discoveries as a consequence of
presumably other things but including
wiping away all this incoming clutter as
you said controlling the top- down
inputs I have to ask just from a
practical standpoint during that one
hour a week are you reading every email
that came in or are you just being very
selective about which emails so you're
not opening most emails no I don't open
most emails amazing no I just I search
for the ones that my assistant
identifies as the one I need to open
there's like a list of things that i'
would be interested in and then we'll go
through the list and then you know
sometimes it requires me to go and find
the email and respond to my myself
because it that is and then I would do
that for 10 you know 10 10 minutes a day
or something do you recommend get out of
there as soon as I can love it um do you
pass on this advice to the people that
you train I think it depends on what
resources and what's your what's the
what's your job right now right so I
think um as a traine I definitely did my
as a assistant professor I did my own
emails but at a certain point um I was
just never getting to the bottom and
then it would just stress me out make me
feel overwhelmed and what is my job my
job is to number
one be a
stable core of a sustainable research
program and um that just requires me
having a lot of mental health and
well-being and um and and
clear-mindedness and I need to be able
to come up with creative ideas I need to
be able to Sprint when there's a
deadline and I I just can't exhaust my
system with
unnecessary I would call them
quadrant four in the time management
quadrant if you're familiar with this
you know uh important urgent certain
things are urgent but not important some
things are Urgent some things are
neither important nor urgent that's most
emails are are like if you read time
management literature and you have the
luxury to have someone else help you or
something that's like so well trained to
be really good at cap chaptering things
that are important and you know
sometimes I miss emails but emails are
not the way my traines would reach me
they would reach me in a different way
um and then emails are for everyone else
that I didn't give my number to you know
I feel so honored to have have your
contact I'd like to take a brief moment
and thank one of our sponsors and that's
ag1 ag1 is a vitamin mineral probiotic
drink that also contains adaptogens I
started taking ag1 way back in 2012 the
reason I started taking it and the
reason I still take it every day is that
it ensures that I meet all of my quotas
for vitamins and minerals and it ensures
that I get enough Prebiotic and
probiotic to support gut health now gut
health is something that over the last
10 years we realized is not just
important for the health of our gut but
also for our immune system and for the
production of neurotransmitters and
neuromodulators things like dopamine and
serotonin in other words gut health is
critical for proper brain functioning
now of course I strive to consume
healthy Whole Foods for the majority of
my nutritional intake every single day
but there are number of things in ag1
including specific micronutrients that
are hard to get from Whole Foods or at
least in sufficient quantities so ag1
allows me to get the vitamins and
minerals that I need probiotics
prebiotics the adaptogens and critical
micronutrients so anytime somebody asks
me if they were to take Just One
supplement what that supplement should
be I tell them ag1 because ag1 supports
so many different systems within the
body that are involved in mental health
physical health and performance to try
ag1 go to drink a1.com huberman and
you'll get a year supply of vitamin D3
K2 and five free travel packs of ag1
again that's drink a1.com
huberman I think this is wonderful
advice for people to hear um we have a
future guest on this podcast named Cal
Newport he wrote the book deep work and
he has another book called A World
Without email he's a computer science
professor at Georgetown where he talks
extensively about the tremendous career
but also relationship and life value of
doing essentially what you're describing
although I do think Kay that you
represent kind of the extreme of what
I've um become aware of in terms of
people that can limit the amount of time
on uh social media platforms and email
anyway I just want to say um
congratulations I just want to say that
again and I think it even if people
don't reduce to one hour per week I
think that making some effort toward
reducing the amount of incoming as you
said controlling the top- down inputs to
the amydala but also to the rest of the
brain involved in Creative processing
Etc is so key and we actually do have
agency it's just it's it's tough um
sometimes to build up that discipline so
you're doing a tremendous service by
sharing that somebody as successful as
you does this presumably is successful
in part because you do this could we by
extension say that many people since
billions of people are on social media
are likely um triggering the activation
of their amygdala clouding out other
more potentially productive activation
of their neural circuits by S just
making themselves freely available to
the to the uh thoughts and words and
impulses of others I mean to me it seems
the answer would be yes but I'd like to
know what you think I mean I think um
and there's something to be said there's
definitely been moments where I've I've
you know gone a deep into social media
and spent more time in a certain burst
right that is isolated and I think that
there's a lot to be learned from social
media so to actually to bring it back to
one point you mentioned earlier um on
social media sometimes people Pro just
want accolades and sometimes there's a
lot of of friction one of the reasons I
stay on social media even though I'm
making this big effort to sort of
declutter my Consciousness is because of
that feedback especially when you know
for someone like you I imagine this has
got to be super true and even for me at
a certain point in my career it just
felt like people don't want to tell me
bad news to my face as much anymore
everybody's so positive all the time and
you know what they what are they really
thinking and social media allows you the
protection of anonymity to say what you
really think without um consequence
essentially and so on the oneand the
consequence-free
um nature of being able to just say
things can be very dangerous but at the
same time for me I really value just
being able to receive it I I'm you know
I'm a big girl I can filter out what I
want when I get the all the inputs but
if I don't receive the inputs sometimes
it's hard to learn from the feedback I'm
not getting so even sometimes feedback
is given in a not very nice way I can
still create a model for someone else
that has this perspective that I can
take with me and that can be another
perspective I can honor easily in the
future because I have this theory of
mind for someone some someone would get
upset about that uh you know that's
something that could be harmful to
people who are think you know have this
theory of mind so I think it's super
valuable from that perspective and
that's why I continue to use
it great yeah I I really applaud that as
well I I always read my teaching evals
because they're Anonymous and yes I do
wonder you know what grade the different
uh people who gave different evals you
know got I don't know that information I
sometimes wonder do they attend the
class or they just angry they didn't do
well on the exam but that really
represents the small fraction of
feedback that I'm um that I wonder about
most of it um that's valuable to me is
the hey you know liked the course but
these parts really sucked Professor
huberman or this part was completely
unclear or completely hated the way you
blank blank and blanked because that
feedback is something I can really work
with to improve so I think um course EV
vals are are similar to what you're
describing I think there's value there
if I were to just look at the the
positive feedback and then ignore the
negative feedback and write those people
off then I don't think I could improve
as a teacher actually I always encourage
comments and feedback and suggestions in
the YouTube comments for this podcast
for that reason and I do read the
comments I go through and I read and um
a few of them sting um but you know the
positive feedback is great too sometimes
it's more of this please y or less of
that please I think there there's
information in that um so I think it
sounds like you've been doing all of
these things naturally I so so actually
then uh since I've had my research group
my my lab um we do an anonymous lab
survey every it's supposed to be about
every 18 months and then it's a whole
long process of going through it and
it's just evolved it's I think it's the
fourth or fifth time we've done it and
so it's now I think it's like 70
questions it's so many question we got
maybe we should we should trim it down
but it it ends up being hundreds of
pages of of text you know short answer
sometimes long answer feedback from
anonymously from people in my lab my lab
is pretty big so it's it's you know I'm
not even trying to really guess who is
saying it it's just feedback and it
takes me months to go through with it
and and get all the feedback and it is
so useful I mean in a class the the the
amount of contact that you have is it's
it's restricted to this very specific
time and space whereas when you're
mentoring someone over the course of
years there's a lot of different
there's a lot of different points of of
content and interaction and you know
you're in the lab all 40 hours a week or
whatever and you know going trip meeting
here there's just a lot of different
different ways to improve and ways we've
never you know I haven't had any
training in how to be a really great
mentor and so I'm getting that training
now I'm making my own course and my
mentees are my teachers and um I really
am grateful for the the tutelage that
they provide for free in this anonym
must lab survey sometimes it makes me
cry but sometimes it makes me feel
really good about something that I'm
doing that's working and in any case it
makes me feel that I have ground truth I
guess I still don't know but when people
say things that sting um it makes me
feel like they're saying what they
really think and they're not holding
back it doesn't you know and um bad news
feels like reality and so that is very
something about that is rewarding
um just to feel like I have reality
rather than I'm getting something else
you know that the model doesn't quite
fit it's very unsatisfying with the
model doesn't quite fit so I love the
word ground truth there's something so
beautiful to that and I I resonate with
um what you're
saying let's go back to social
interaction something that your lab is
doing um lots of work on nowadays and
maybe we could shift to the sorts of
social interaction that most of us are
familiar with with the um sitting across
the table having a coffee with somebody
the taking a walk with somebody maybe a
phone call yeah um maybe a tough
conversation um maybe a playful you know
um you know unscripted conversation um
maybe a meal at a holiday dinner you
know there's a huge range there what
what do we know about the value of
social
interaction at the level of sort of core
biological needs like at the level of
neural circuits and maybe even hormones
I mean you know most people have heard
of oxytocin they think the love hormone
but it's there's so much more there for
people to understand and know about you
know how important is this thing that we
call social interaction and how bad do
things get when we're not getting the
right kinds of social interaction you
know I think this is this is a great
question and I'm glad that it's become
something that has been recognized at a
more global a national scale just the
importance of of having social support
in our lives for heal for our well-being
um but social isolation or even just
perceived loneliness has immense Health
consequences for all social species so
um shortened
lifespan
increased mood
disorders um increased actually
morbidity and mortality for disease like
cancer or heart disease that you know um
might not be what we would normally
think and so I think understanding how
each of those processes is happening
those mechanisms are far from being
worked out but the the correlational
evidence is undeniable we're now taking
this into the lab really for the first
time and so something so simple as
social isolation how can we don't know
way more about it and um I'm someone who
stumbled into the field field of social
isolation by accident prior to the
pandemic and so I'll just say you know
the whole story on why there's such a
gaping hole in our knowledge as a
neuroscience Community about social
isolation really comes from Harry haro's
work this original work of maternal
separation that was undeniably cruel it
it caused irreparable damage to these
baby monkeys and they never recovered
and sorry to interrupt apologize I'm
striving to not interrupt in my life but
I but so that people are on on board um
could you just briefly describe the
harlo experiments yes so they're very
famous experiments where they separated
uh baby monkeys from their moms and then
had either a wire sort of thing holding
a bottle so okay what what do you miss
most about the mom is it the wire is it
the food or is it the the the comfort
and then they had
so they had a wire thing with with a
milk bottle versus you know blankets and
cuddly soft things and and the the baby
monkeys would go to the cuddly soft
thing but you know a blanket is not a
replacement for a mother nobody's saying
that it is and and through these
experiments there was extended maternal
separation and it's it it was deemed
cruel um there was permanent irreparable
damage when you when you rehouse these
monkeys they never resocialized normally
they had lots of different mental and
physical health problems um and I think
in humans we know that so you know
solitary confinement is considered
torture um you know social isolation is
a difficult thing to study in in a lot
of
conditions and we stumbled onto it by
complete accident through working with a
postto a former postdoc in my lab
Jullian Matthews who was a graduate
student um doing an experiment on on it
was just trying to figure out if these
dopamine neurons um would also respond
to cocaine the way VTA these sorry these
vental tegmental area dopamine earons
were known to respond to cocaine wanted
to see if these other dopamin respond to
cocaine so sort of a incremental study
so when you do these cocaine studies you
you inject the animal with cocaine or
saline and they leave the naive animal
in the cage and then you take brain
slices record from the neurons and look
at the synaptic strengths and so you
know the expected outcome sort of was
that these dopamine NS would would be
similar to other dopamine nands that
showed in you know long- lasting
potentiation after a single dose of
cocaine but what happened instead was
that yes there was potentiation in the
cocaine animals there's also
potentiation in the saline animals
relative to the naive group and this was
a huge puzzle what was this and it
turned out through many many different
experiments um that it's actually
because when you inject animals with
cocaine you're separating them from the
group they I act all crazy and this is
what the way people did the experiment
so you inject them with saline you
separate them the naive animals just
stay there so with their other their
other litter mates I see so the control
group The saling control group is
actually a social isolation condition so
by accident this control group that
didn't make sense was how we stumbled
onto so then we tried is it novel cage
it's not the novel cage it's the it's
the social isolation and so um that is
how we became a lab that studied social
isolation it was complete accident we
weren't sure what what we were looking
at and then um we man we found these
neurons and we manipulate these neurons
and they
produced um something very different
than other dopamine neurons which
normally if you stimulate dopamine
neurons these ventral tental area
mid-brain dopam like 90% of the time
when you you hear people talk about
dopamine they mean these ones and
they're the ones where you press a lever
stimulate the nerves we'll press a lever
thousands of times you know and they
love to be stimulated yes and if if
you're a human and you do cocaine you
you most people love cocaine they they
want they're very pro-social when
they're on cocaine and so that's what
dopamine neurons were thought to be
doing but these other dopamine neurons
in the dorsal rap that I will also say
is in the brain stem near to an aqueduct
where you could detect signals from the
body um but these other dopamine neurons
in the raap they when you stimulate them
animals don't like it they will not work
for reward they actually will move away
from a space that's where they're being
stimulated you know condition place and
real-time Place aversion I don't like
the feeling of these neurons being
activated please stop it and yet they
would be pro-social and so for a long
time this was super confusing we
couldn't understand it and then just
because at the same time we had a um a
hunger study going on in the lab we just
thought about it like I can eat food
because it's delicious and I I want to
eat this yummy treat or I can eat
because I'm super hungry I feel shaky
I'm just to eat this nasty fiber bar out
of my backpack CU I'm so desperate and I
need like I need my my blood sugar is
dangerously low you know and so there's
two reasons that you can eat and one of
them is uncomfortable hunger is not
comfortable you don't it's not a good
feeling to be hungry and so we thought
about this and that's kind of how we
circularly came around to thinking I
think we've discovered the loneliness
neurons essentially and so what is
loneliness and loneliness is this
unpleasant need state of wanting social
contact that would have this
pro-social effect as well and so um
that's basically the very serendipitous
loop-de-loop way that I came to be um uh
studying how loneliness is represented
in the brain amazing before we talk a
bit more about these loneliness neurons
and some of their inputs and outputs in
the brain
um how has the discovery of these
neurons um perhaps changed the way that
you organize your day and week and life
right um if at all um for instance are
you more aware of how much time you
spend alone versus with others are you
um more careful or Discerning about who
you spend your time with um you know I I
asked this um because you know there's
so many examples for me in the
Neuroscience literature where you know I
learned something new about how the
brain works and I think oh yeah you know
it makes a lot of sense why my sleep
isn't great you know it turns out that
light exposure to the eyes at particular
times of day really sets the whole body
and brain into particular rhythms that
you know explain why I was a little
depressed when I was in graduate school
staying up all night doing experiments
and I'd sleep much of the day and feel
like I was getting eight nine hours I
don't get eight to nine hours now but um
you know and when I wake up early for me
personally there's a bit of an
anti-depressant effect as long as I
slept the night before seasonal effect
disorder is real right so you know I
think as new information comes online um
at least for me it's it's changed the
way that I organize my life to to s in
subtle or or in not so subtle ways so
the idea that there are neurons in the
brain that encode loneliness the absence
of social contact does that have you
thinking you know after a few days of
managing the lab uh with which as you
point out you have a very large lab lots
of social interaction but it's work
context social interaction does that um
has that led you to think hey you know
we should go out to dinner as a lab or I
should spend time with somebody who's
not in science um or I should spend time
by myself because I've had too much
social interaction I'm not asking for
strict protocols here I'm just wondering
if you're willing to get um like play in
the sandbox of this with me a bit um how
this information perhaps has shaped some
of your choices you personally and and
be very clear I'm not asking you to
dictate what other people do um has it
changed your social life so it's really
interesting that you ask this question
and now that you you know now that
you're asking it this way
um I I mean of course when I learn new
things I I I um take them and Implement
them into my life but to be honest in in
the cycle of of of you know learning and
studying and being curious and I
actually think where I reside more is
when something's going on with me my
research program you know research is
research it becomes what the re it
dictates what the research program
evolves into and so for ex for example
so I've just had started studying
loneliness um a few years before the
pandemic hit and then the pandemic hit
and it was just a step function like
change I went from I'm never alone
unless you call being in an Uber Alone
um or being on a plane and and and just
you know constantly people in my office
even when I'm going to the bathroom
someone's waiting for me outside like
you know I'm not it's like I'm hurrying
in the bathroom I'm never alone there's
like four people in my bed kicking me in
the face I'm just you know there's just
so much Social contact and then boom you
know there would
be a day I wouldn't see another like you
know just the a not zero but just
extremely sudden drop of social contact
when there's no more work and you know
it was just that that period of time
and it was it was very depressing it was
just this huge I felt like I was in
freef fall and it made me you know at
first it was really disruptive and I was
worried about myself you know and then
at some point I adjusted to it and then
I got used to working from home I got
started a garden like I got all this you
know I got you know I just started a
different life pattern that involved a
lot of alone time and you know something
an alone time personal life AG grew
where there wasn't any space for
anything to grow before and then I
became comfortable with it and so then I
started thinking about that that's
really where the idea of social
homeostasis was born this idea that okay
why is it with acute social isolation
humans monkeys mice you know you acutely
isolate the individual from the social
group you reintroduce them to the social
group rebound of pro-social interaction
oh so happy to see you there's like all
these affiliative interactions a Hu a
burst of affiliative interactions
whereas with chronic social isolation in
humans monkeys mice even
flies you reintroduced into the social
group and you get territorial Behavior
aggression avoidance antisocial behavior
um or just you know sort of a very
different negative veillance response to
the exposure to the group and so this
maybe people brushed it off for a long
time is just oh it's confusing this
literature is inconsistent or maybe
there's one model that makes it all make
sense that is social home homeostasis
where you know you're used to getting
this at a certain point and so my
affector system gets activated I I
detect that I'm alone it's I want more
the deficits detected then my affector
systems gets activated this and then I
start spinning all the systems that try
to get me back into contact I'm calling
my friends I'm texting my friend I'm I'm
if I'm a mouse I'm making ultrasonic
vocalizations I'm exploring outside of
the burrow and then you know if my
friends don't call me back they're like
sorry we don't want to see anyone till
end of covid bye whatever it is you know
you it's it's not working my correction
efforts are failing or maybe a certain
amount of time we don't know then I give
up I stop I stop calling I stop going
out I just make a different life you
know you the the the they don't you
don't leave the burrow whatever it is
and there's in in animal and humans at
least behaviorally there's a near step
function like drop off of attempts to
you know you can see sort of dat oh then
they just give up on dating after this
one you know whatever happens there's
some some straw that breaks the camels
back and then this person doesn't want
to date anymore or doesn't want to go
out anymore whatever and and what is
that so that adaptation then you're at a
new Baseline you're You're Expecting now
your new normal I'm I'm expecting to
have a gardening day at home alone not
see anyone and then and then a bunch of
people come over feels like a surplus so
my previous Optimum you know
reintroduction to the social
group is now feeling like a surplus an
overload overstimulated and that's I
think something that a lot of people
experience this Whiplash of going into
the pandemic and coming out of it
different people to different levels it
depends on how much you you know
isolated while you were in the pandemic
but I think thinking about um your
social set point as being flexible and
dynamic Was A New Concept to me and then
in my mind the question is what is the
part of this process that is causing all
these harmful Health consequences like
shorten lifespan mood disorders Etc is
it the initial detection that I'm
missing something and affect your system
activation because if that was the case
maybe I want to Band-Aid that you know
maybe I want to get get a pet get a get
a get a zoom buddy I don't know what you
know you would have different
prescriptions and advice to give people
that were the case versus you would give
almost opposite advice if the thing
that's causing it is the the set point
adaptation then you want to you want to
save it off versus if you wanted to
accelerate getting into the set point
which is better you know is it the
adaptation or is it you know kind of
trying to fix it and so in one case you
would want to ease off the the having
the set point happen the set point
transition happen in the other case rip
it off like a Band-Aid cold turkey Just
Adjust and then you'll be fine you know
then you won't worry about it then you
won't be lonely anymore cuz you'll just
be comfortable being alone you know
people talk about cognitive flexibility
um and I think it's it's sort of like
that but it's social flexibility I want
to be able to be alone I also want to be
able to be in a large group and be
comfortable and so I think what I've
done if anything to change my lifestyle
um to accommodate these new insights
I've had is is to
consciously create Dynamic social
experience
lots of social experiences yes but also
protecting alone time which I never did
before I just I just just gave it all
away and you know I realized that having
that just made my social homeostatic
system feel more elastic and flexible
and resilient and less like a crisis if
something you know I'm I'm very
comfortable being alone I'm super
comfortable with my own skin now and it
requires investing in that relationship
I like how you framed uh earlier I think
we were not not recording yet but the
relationship with yourself as being a
very important relationship and um when
I think about brain States you know we
don't know this yet but my working model
would be that different individuals we
represent their identities and whenever
they're present it creates a unique
Ensemble of that combination of people
being present and being alone is also a
unique state that cannot be achieved I
have the brain state of being alone I
cannot achieve it if anyone else is
around
and that's just what you know that's
kind of the working model I have I think
what you're saying is uh essential for
people to hear because um it makes sense
that loneliness would hurt um it makes
sense that some people are more
extroverted which I think is defined as
getting energy from social interactions
and resetting energy through social
interactions as opposed to introverted
which by the way folks introverts like
myself do enjoy social interaction it's
just that we reset through more um Solo
or one-on-one time than we do in larger
groups that's my understanding of the
introversion extroversion literature we
can revisit that but this notion of
social homeostasis is I think so key uh
important enough that I think we
probably want
to redefine it um as many times or
restate it rather as many times as it's
necessary because I believe what you're
describing is the same thing that one
would experience with food if we eat a
lot we're consuming I know 3500 calories
a day and then um suddenly we only have
access to 1,800 calories a day there's
it feels like a deficit because indeed
it is whereas after some period of time
at 1,800 calories a day 2200 calories a
day feels like relative abundance
relative abundance
um when the pandemic hit I certainly um
was unhappy about the State of Affairs
in the world of course um but I recall
feeling like oh my goodness I finally
don't have to commute 90 minutes in each
direction to Stanford because I lived in
the East Bay at that time um I felt like
I had time to do things I hadn't done in
a long time and thanks to zoom I was
able to get certain things done not
others then after about six to eight
months when I realized this is going to
carry on for a while I remember feeling
quite lonely and making some efforts to
repair that I I
think social media not to harp on social
media um could do either one of two
things and I don't know which in the
context of uh social
homeostasis either going on Instagram
and seeing a lot of familiar faces and
comments and accounts could make me feel
like I'm getting some social interaction
such that then when I close that app and
move to my work at my desk or something
uh which these days is mostly done um
solo um that I would feel like I had
social interaction or perhaps it's the
equivalent of um
calories that um then makes me feel more
isolated when I'm not in the app
perhaps I find it to be distinctly
different than like the experience I had
last night of going to dinner with
someone I know quite well sitting down
and having a open-ended conversation and
deciding to close out the night only
when we realized you know we got to get
up tomorrow for work so went our
separate ways um there's something that
felt very s ating about it so I wonder
in this context of social homeostasis
whether or not the analogy of social
interaction to caloric intake if we
could is there another dimension to it
where it's not just the total number of
calories or the total amount of social
interaction but the quality of social
interaction the type of social
interaction that actually feels like
nourishment as opposed to just calories
I love where you're going with this and
and so um when we wrote this review the
first time we know we're we're conceptu
this idea of of how your social set
point can change based on if if you're
acutely isolated or or chronically
isolated and
um the Y AIS is the quality quantity of
detected social contact which is so
fuzzy and you know there's it's it's
again one of the most challenging
frontiers of this field because how even
if we measure every single component
that the brain can detect of the social
the social contact so much of it is
about expectation you know like if I
think I got a gesture if if I get a nod
from the president I'm like oh my god
did the president just nod at me that's
so exciting versus if I get a nod from
my partner I'm like oh my God are they
mad at me what's going on why why did I
just get a nod right it totally matters
the gesture you need the identity
there's many
different cognitive systems that need to
all plug in to this wheel um
to make it spin so I think that uh that
is one of the the I I think that's going
to keep us busy for a
while but in terms of your question
about social media and when you switch
from you know getting social media
feedback and then doing work um I think
I think it really depends I mean social
media is such a large category you can
have many different types of responses
generally I think the bounds so you know
when you say social media versus real
life interaction where you're with
someone maybe you're touching maybe
you're not touching but even if you're
having conversation um you have
interbrain synchrony you are um having a
lot of interbrain syn you're in the same
place if but you can have interbrain
synchrony even on the phone right just a
voice call is actually a lot more
interbrain synchrony than than messages
I think I think text messages can bring
a lot of anxiety and there's been a lot
of commentary about that um and same
thing with with with social media I
think the the thing about social media
that is perhaps um the
most harmful or NE negative I think in
terms of I when I'm thinking about
social nourishment if I you know sort of
making that term up on the Fly here but
um it's it's almost a withdrawal when
social media is posted it's not to you
it's to everyone and you could be one of
the people that receives this message
but it's not even what to you I'm not
not even talking to you and I'm doing
something that's without you otherwise
you'd be in this picture and not reading
on social media listening to whatever so
it's like by almost exclusively you're
you're posting about activities that
you're being excluded from and someone's
not even really talking to you unless
they're D you know direct messaging you
but then I I kind of consider that a
different category if it's like a
onetoone communication social media to
me is is a blast right it's not it's
just you know catching up with someone
on social media I I don't really see the
Merit of it because is I'll just catch
up with them when I catch up with them
and their kids will just be like way
older but you know I don't know I'll
actually really catch up with them then
just see pictures of you know I don't
know I I feel mixed about it because
it's not a real connection and it
doesn't for me Sate my social appetite
to catch up with to to look at someone
else's profile on on social media um
that doesn't actually do anything for
the the connection I I don't know but I
seriously doubt tons of oxytocin is
released when I you know follow
someone's feed about their vacation so I
don't know I would I think that it
definitely matters the quality and
social media is is different than real
life interactions for many reasons I'd
like to take a quick break and thank our
sponsor insid tracker insid tracker is a
personalized nutrition platform that
analyzes data from your blood and DNA to
help you better understand your body and
help you reach your health goals now
I've long been a believe lever in
getting regular blood work done for the
simple reason that many of the factors
that impact your immediate and long-term
Health can only be analyzed from a
quality blood test a major problem with
a lot of blood tests out there however
is that you get information back about
metabolic factors lipids and hormones
and so forth but you don't know what to
do with that information with inside
tracker they make it very easy because
they have a personalized platform that
allows you to see the levels of all
those things metabolic factors lipids
hormones Etc but it gives you specific
directives that you can follow that
relate to nutrition behavioral
modifications supplements Etc that can
help you bring those numbers into the
ranges that are optimal for you if you'd
like to try insid tracker you can go to
insid tracker.com huberman to get 20%
off any of insid tracker's plans again
that's insid
tracker.com huberman I really appreciate
your willingness to uh explore in this
uh in this context I
think your mention of the fact that um
real life interaction involves
interbrain synchrony could be by text
scaling up from that by phone um
FaceTime or something akin to that video
video chat um on social media there is
comments back and forth um although
that's timec consuming and it's
difficult because there's anonymity
people are in different places different
time zones if you don't know someone
it's different context um so I'm really
thanks to what you're describing I'm
really starting to think about social
media as so different than in-person
social interactions or by phone or video
chat social interactions and how those
would differentially impact social
homeostasis and it's leading me at least
to conclude that at least for me that
most social media interactions would
create more
hunger as opposed to a um sting of of
the need for social interaction it's um
I have to be careful with the analogies
here but since I can do this I I was
almost going to make analogy between um
porn pornography
uhhuh inperson sexual intimacy I suppose
there's something in between where
people could talk by phone but we don't
want to explore this in any kind of
salacious way and then um sexual
intimacy with with uh with emotion with
positive emotion right those there's a
scaling Factor there and I'm not P I'm
not putting um judgment or veilance I'm
I'm certainly not that's not my place as
a good friend of mine says I'm not a cop
you know I'm not telling people what to
do they can't do but it's so interesting
to think about these um these circuits
within us that create these what you and
I in our field call repetitive the
desire for or aversive the desire to
move away from type responses and how so
much of our life aside from you because
you're regulating your social media and
your uh and your email intake but so
much of Life Now is offering us the
opportunity to um tickle these circuits
or even hit them hard with a
sledgehammer but we're not thinking
about these homeostatic mechanisms of
whether or not they're creating more
hunger for or more satisfaction from
yeah and I I I cannot emphasize enough
how critical this is and I think that's
because you know I'm somebody who does
spend a fair amount of time on social
media a lot of my my work exists on
social media YouTube Etc and I would
hope that the work that we're putting
into the world with this podcast is
creating a a satiation of the desire for
information rather than a Hunger for
More I do hope that but I recognize that
educational material on social media
represents the the a tiny tiny fraction
of what's there so social homeostasis I
think is a term that if people haven't
already stamped into their mind they
should be stamping into their mind and
and Dr K Tai deserves credit for that I
don't uh I will say that so you don't
have to
um I've heard you say before you wrote
in a review something akin to social
contact is either positive or negative
when it's deficient or in excess which
is I think what you're describing is is
social homeostasis is that right when we
talked about the quality and quantity um
there's just in terms of contact just
amount of contact there's such a thing
as just the right amount there's some
thing is too little there's such a thing
as too much there's overcrowding right
it doesn't matter who it it can be your
family it could just sometimes it's like
a lot maybe your family depends depend
you know the famous ROM dos quote no
think you're enlightened go spend a
weekend with your
parents no no disrespect Mom and Dad I
know right um but
um I think with quality it matters so
much like I was sort of saying before
you know the same gesture from the
president or my partner it's going to
feel very different to me whether that
was a slight or uh you know it's just
it's relative to what is appropriate for
our rank for our prior history
relationships for you know the the
environmental context and so I think
with social media in general and I agree
social media is great for a lot of
things I mean I and I I I think that
having a podcast like this that is
accessible to the public makes research
more sustainable so I have a lot of
things to say about science
communication that I'm very you know
grateful for but in terms of social
media think about the mutual investment
when you are interacting with someone on
soci social media what are they
investing in this connection so if I put
out a post about my vacation that is
public I'm investing
00000000000000 one% of my bandwidth to
make contact with you you know what I
mean and so it's it it scales up from
them if if you're making a voice call
with someone you're giving them at least
most of your attention for the time that
you're on the call that's a lot right
whereas you know so so just thinking
about the investment is another
component there's the real time
component and then there's the the
investment component who is it coming
from it matters if you're anonymous I
really I cannot tell what this means you
know a compliment from an or or a hate
hate comment or a love comment from
Anonymous
person I don't know what to do with this
you like I just literally don't know how
to you know it doesn't really doesn't
really do anything for me because I
don't know how to interpret it it's
almost you know uninterpretable without
this other dimension that my brain is
has evolved to look for I think so
that's you know
speculation but I think social media is
is operating in a way that that is not
ethological and not designed to make us
feel better it's just designed to make
us want to use it and I think a lot of
this comes down to things that are
relative you know there's the famous um
there's the famous observations if of a
m monkey sees Another Monkey get a
cucumber it's happy with the Cucumber
but if a monkey sees the other monkey
get great grape monkey wants grape you
know you want you want to keep up with
the Joneses you want what if you see
someone else having something suddenly
it feels like a loss that you don't have
it that you didn't even think that of
this thing that you needed right and so
I think social media is exposing you to
a lot of things that you don't you know
that it's it's like this this parameter
space you didn't have there's all these
things you didn't know you were missing
that you didn't need to miss out on and
so we have this whole project now we
have two projects one that's looking at
social isolation and following what
happens with social isolation across the
time course to try to understand is it
the amount of time or is it the amount
of effort that you put into correcting
that deficit um that that makes you
leads you to the giving up you know kind
of state change and another project that
um is about the quality of social
contact specifically social exclusion so
a different kind of deficit you're with
your other animals but there's this this
you know it's four animals that have um
are cagemates and um three animals are
on one side able to drink a chocolate
milkshake and the other animals ex
excluded and this one excluded animal
will go up against the the divider and
and you know look look frantic and you
know ex exhibit lots of behaviors that
we would associate in humans with fear
of missing out trying to reunite with
the group trying to get the attention of
the group trying to get over there a lot
of attending looks
frantic and studying what we think is
actually going on and so I think that I
think coming up with paradigms to try to
probe social isolation and we don't even
know what behaviors animals exhibit when
they're lonely this is this is a
challenging field because there's no
number of lever presses you know there's
no there's no script to follow and
there's no trial structure and so for a
neuroscientist NE neur scientists were
trained to be rigorous about our
statistics because of the stochastic
nature of neural neural activity and you
know how do we process things without a
trial structure how do we be
statistically rigorous when the animal
is just free floating deciding whatever
it wants to do and so that is kind of
The Crucible that my lab is is working
through right now to establish pipelines
and techniques and ways to
quantify social behavor avors and peel
off all the
layers I love where your lab is headed
which just means we're going to have to
have you back on here again at some
point in the future to get the answers
to those questions that you're now
addressing I've long thought that we
really know how we feel about somebody
when something good happens to them or
for them and I never quite understood
this at the level of mechanisms how
could I it's not more my lab studies but
you know I think that there's a natural
sort of empathy if one is a healthy uh
empathic person to seeing a member of
our own species and hopefully uh also to
observing the members of other species
um you know experiencing some discomfort
we don't like that nor should we so
another human is in emotional pain right
um you know the whale or the Cry of loss
is like one that just I think for any
person who's empathically attuned is
just like uh or an animal you hear an
animal in pain like goodness I mean I'm
not here to diagnose sociopathy but if
if that doesn't evoke a at least some
sort of response of like oh gosh like
what I wouldn't do to remove that pain
that their pain is your pain empathy um
that seems like a very reflexive circuit
or at least I would hope so um but when
somebody experiences something positive
I think it's normal and healthy to to
have a um a graded set of responses if
it's somebody that we really love um we
may not even know them we think yeah
like you're you just reflexively happy
for them um somebody that we dislike I
think there's a more natural tendency to
be like oh you know right you know as as
opposed to if that person were in pain I
would like to think that even if one
didn't like them that you would think
like oh that that sucks I'm really sorry
to hear that um so I feel like there's
some asymmetry in these empathic
interactions they're both empathy one
has negative veilance pain the other one
has positive veilance another member of
our species or other species receiving
reward and we can Delight in that I mean
I I'm almost embarrassed to admit how
many freret and Otter and raccoon
accounts I follow because I love seeing
them eat I love seeing the little hands
of the raccoons there's some great
raccoon accounts by the way um and I
Delight in it I like Delight in it I
want to see the raccoons win I don't
know why I just I love animals and so I
suppose that's why um so do you think
that there that we are asymmetrically
wired for this empathic Attunement um
can we observe that in other animals I
realize this might not be squarely in
the Wheelhouse of what your lab is
focusing on but I think it it relates
enough to the topics that we're covering
today that just you know if you'd like
to speculate um uh on what might be
going on there yeah I I I can definitely
speculate something that we think about
a lot but again you know I there's some
there's some level of this which is
semantics um I think of empathy as being
defined as being able to understand
another animal's emotion and also taking
it on so I think um something that's a
little bit different than emotional
contagion right I see a panic I'm going
a group with P it's not the same thing
as uh as as empathy um empathy is often
used in in sort of certain contexts like
feeling sorry for someone and it's maybe
different if for feeling happy for
someone and this is something I was just
talking about with one of my graduate
students the other day why is there is
is there an
asymmetry in in empathy for positive and
negative or is it just what we've
studied it's easier to study this so
there's a number of you know we don't
know the answer but I guess another
conceptual framework to put out there
I'm not saying it's correct it's I think
just a a good tool for debate but um
it's not so much that there's good
people and bad people and that good
people are empathic and bad people
aren't uh so you it's not quite so
simple I I guess the way I think about
it is whether you view this other social
agent as having
aligned goals or agendas as you or are
they adversarial so if they're if
they're in in your alliance whatever
that means broadly defined versus
adversarial you would have a different
feeling and you know it's it's you see
this I guess I was just I was just
watching this okay this is just sort of
oversharing but this is a podcast not a
a primary research Journal so I can just
say things right so I I watch some trash
TV sometimes and you know these reality
competition shows where it's like then
you vote the two best friends into
elimination and they have to they have
to eliminate each other mildly sadistic
but you know then they're best friends
and they like like they you know and
then it's basically mutually exclusive
either you can care about your friend
and feel bad not wanting to send them
home
or you you kick it you just you know you
it's game time and you you you
and so you can see different individuals
wrestling with these two brain States
and and how to like what to do but they
are essentially you know my my my
speculation is that viewing someone as a
competitor and they're an adversary they
are standing in the way of me getting
what I want you empathy goes down it's
like inversely correlated to empathy if
you are viewed as a competitor so things
that would contribute to you creating a
model where an in a social agent it is
an adversary as opposed to an a
potential ally is really what it's going
to come down to to the degree that you
feel empathy you know like you the
second someone you realize someone's out
to get you no empathy no and no more
empathy for this person who I just
realized is out to get me or something
like that or you know uh in the case of
being isolated for a long period of time
you've learned to exist on your own now
maybe everyone's your competitor or
adversary you know and none of you guys
are really helping me do my day like I
don't really need you guys for anything
so so I'm eating this food or whatever
you know I think it just becomes
different um when you're part of an
ecosystem and you realize that you know
there's consequences and there's there's
EV every action that you take you know
every Act of altruism will be recognized
and there you know there's there's
there's a there's some score being kept
in your when you're part of a society
and um and then when you're when you're
not there's none there's there's none of
that and so I think the degree to which
you're integrated in society um it's
almost like the extracellular Matrix you
know this is a really this is an out
there analogy but you know when you
think about synapses being made um
connections between people there's also
all the support material that
facilitates certain patterns and certain
connections from happening or not
happening and and I think um that's it's
it's stuff that we haven't Quantified
yet but it doesn't you know I think
those things should be studied years ago
I worked with at risk kids and and a
fair number of them had just arrived um
from a region of the world that had
undergone dramatic
sociopolitical um Evolution um and
change and it was remarkable because we
would put out a tray of food to eat and
then the the format was everyone would
serve themselves and then um you could
uh go get more food if if you if
everyone
finished um and a couple of these kids
that had come from these very deprived
environments um would just take a more
than their their share it was clear that
by taking that other kids weren't going
to get any and um and I remember telling
them listen we all have to eat more or
less equal parts and then we can there
is more we can get more and um I'll
never forget this kid's response he just
turned to me and he said you can't hit
us and I said that's true I can't hit
you and he and he said so I'm just going
to take as much as I want and this took
several weeks actually to to work out
right um CU of course I would never hit
him and um but everyone's his adversary
everyone's his adversary and it was
remarkable to see the evolution of these
kids across that it was about three and
a half weeks um at which point they
actually became
incredibly um good at sharing um but it
it took a lot of work it was almost as
if even though they knew more tra of
food could arrive yeah not Limitless but
there was there was an abundance of food
yeah in the moment they they were
solving for that short Horizon moment
yeah and it and here we're talking about
human beings capable of speech and
expression of emotion Etc and he
understood the fundamental rule which
was I couldn't hit him therefore he
could basically do what he wanted
without that
consequence and which the main
consequence he faced apparently exactly
and um and I remember you know it was it
was so striking I'll never forget that
and the evolution to a different more um
altruistic state was wonderful
especially because of what I think what
it did for him but but I'll never forget
thinking this is a human being who's
essentially functioning like an
animal like an animal I mean I had a
Bulldog Mastiff and he was kind to other
dogs but if there
were unattended to toys at the dog park
he was going to pick them up and he put
him right in front of himself and his
this was down San Diego and he sit with
them right in front of him and I'm like
Costello you're not going to play with
all those toys but if another dog came
and and he wouldn't he would just sit in
front of them but another dog would come
and try and take one of those toys and
he would he had these giant mitts and he
would just boom Stam it out and drag it
back and so it seems that there are
these very primitive circuits about uh
resource allocation and protection of
resources that in the absence of
understanding that there's a much bigger
landscape like Costello eventually
figured out like tug's a fun game
although most dogs couldn't play tug
with him there were a few that could he
was a 90b bulldog he was just a neck
like this but you know to see this in a
human being was just so striking I just
as you're describing this it's like this
adversary versus um neutral versus uh
friend it is just so striking and it's
got to be you know that that the brain
as complex as it is I've often wondered
and our colleague Marcus Meister once
said that you know C cirs in the brain
um Can broadly be divided into these
sorts of circuits into yum yuck and me
right Which is far too simplistic right
but who am I to argue with the great
Marcus Meister um and I'm not going to
but it's sort of interesting we sort of
Bin our responses into yes okay let
let's cooperate or yes let's cooperate
you're summarizing veence yeah or or no
way no chance like mine yeah versus like
me me and um you know as complex as I'd
like to think the brain is and we are I
mean maybe when it comes down to
behaviors and how we interpret input and
our
decision-making um maybe it's really all
about feelings of safety and feelings of
um relatedness yeah I think it's also
about the IR experiential statistics
that you have been exposed to so this
this boy who says you I'm going to take
all this food because you can't hit me I
mean we don't don't know but the the
picture that grows out of my imagination
is this boy had a lot of experiences of
people hitting them a lot of experiences
of not enough
food and not a lot of experiences of
strangers being nice to them you know
like not a lot of people that you could
trust that's the that's the experiential
statistics that would fit this
model someone like like you who's coming
in being like Oh no there's more I'm
going to give you guys more food for
free you know I'm going to give you even
more food for it's you know it the
experiential statistics are you come
from a world of abundance where people
are gener you know generosity being
you've learned being generous can make
you have a lifelong friend and all these
amazing opportunities that make your
quality of life that food is you're
never going to think about food again
it's about the relationships because
that's your experiential statistics and
so I think this is such a profound
concept about about neuroscience and the
Brain about our social structures and
how they form what makes a structure
egalitarian or
despotic right like how how can we as
individuals take a structure that is is
one format let's say despotic hierarchy
and evolve it into something that's more
egalitarian and um what are what are the
the the levers and what are the
parameter spaces that we can pull on and
I think these are questions
that I mean it's hard to think of what
could be more important um but that
perspective of thinking about from
experiential statistics I think really
supports you know the need of of of
diversity having bringing in people to
Academia whove had very different
experiences experiential statistics
different biases of what they're going
to think is interesting to work on and
study and obviously in every every
sector of our society so I think
um how can we get more diverse sets of
experiences
represented at each decision-making body
that really
matters yeah Amen to that and also to be
able to understand that um differences
in background experience um require that
we we earlier you mentioned theory of
mind this ability to get into the
mindset of others and and sort of assume
or presume certain mindsets in order to
hopefully create a more benevolent
environment for everybody um
you know it requires um you know
realizing that some people's social
interactions are you know have been
terrible or traumatic or um you know it
requires a departure from self
essentially it requires this empathy or
something like empathy um in all
directions right I mean in all
directions it requires that everyone at
least makes some effort to try and
understand that I do wonder and maybe
someone would put on the comments on
YouTube maybe maybe you're aware um K of
um whether or
not kids are being trained in that
beautiful period of time of life where
neuroplasticity is so robust um although
it does continue throughout the right
lifespan it is especially robust early
in life to um to be in a healthy way
empathically attuned to be able to have
theory of mind more robust theory of
mind yeah so I think it's it's really I
mean I'm I'm so I'm a parent I have two
kids that are in public school and I
think their Public Schools rated you
know it's fine Buton say it's all right
and um but but at their school they
definitely do get education about um
more holistic health and emotional
regulation I think and and considering
others um that's been that's that's a
big focus of the school and I think
that's actually really important I I I I
mean you know again I'm I'm super biased
from from my upbringing but my kids are
going to learn math whenever it's time
to learn the that they'll learn it
whenever they need it you know whenever
they need it they're going to learn it
in a couple I don't know a couple weeks
and figure out do the thing um most of
the things that they learn they're going
to forget them and then have to relearn
them um so what are the things that
you're going to really need to know no
matter what you choose to do and I think
regulating your your own emotions and
and and engaging other individuals in a
healthy sustainable way that you know
and I mean sustainable in terms of the
longevity of their relationships and I
think those are the things that end up
really mattering so I think um also this
question about exposure to abundance and
scarcity uh is really interesting too I
mean I don't know if that's a direction
we want to go into so please yeah well I
think you know this whole you know it
sort sounds sort of new Agy when I say
you know abundant the abundance mindset
right um I mean you see this in people
who are like uh recently divorced or
newly single for whatever reason like is
is the world a place where like finding
um partnership is is relatively
straightforward with some work involved
um or is it like well there's only one
person on the planet for you and they
might be dead already right like um is
there PL if someone else's business
takes off maybe someone you went to
college or high school with or their lab
is doing really well you're seeing them
you know tremendously successful that
maybe they made a $100 million in a in a
new in a company acquisition do you
immediately feel like oh those are
resources that I don't have um even
though I'm not in that business um or do
you see it as wow that there must be a
lot of money out there that um that
people could earn and and potentially
make I really you know prescribe and
believe in this abundance versus
scarcity mindset
framework um I think there's absolutes
like the example we just talked about
this the the kid you know there's just
not food there's scarcity of food fact
you know of course there are individuals
that experience scarcity of various
different needs but many of us we reach
a threshold of abundance and then it
becomes relative we have everything we
absolutely physiologically need if we're
not comparing ourselves to anyone else
but then once we were enter the social
Arena comparison is essential why do we
compare ourselves to others it's it's
ingrain because social status is
something that we need to attend to a
large part of our our our brain is
devoted to representing our relative
social rank what's our place with a
social network what's the dynamic how do
we fit into the social landscape and
comparison I think is just a way to do
that that's that's been evolutionarily
conserved perhaps for less of a good
purpose at this point because so many of
our basic survival needs are met for the
large majority of of humans on the
planet today not not for everybody of
course but so yet what is the percentage
of humans who feel they have everything
that they desire how many people feel
like they don't want for anything and
you know it's interesting because having
things doesn't make
you have an abundance mindset having
abundance does not is not sufficient to
give you the mindset of
abundance that's such an important
statement I mean just I don't think they
could be restated enough
um you've studied social rank mhm uh
people hear social Rank and hierarchy
and I have to guess that at least some
neurons in their amydala and other areas
of the brain get buzzing because as soon
as people hear social
rank they I think naturally started
think well where am I in this social
Rank and um how do I feel about how that
rank is you know established and and all
sorts of interesting and important
questions um some people get very angry
that there are billionaires on this
planet M especially given that in most
major cities you don't have to go very
far to see people who have very limited
uh
resources
so social rank is something that um I
think exists in every little niche like
you know at work and maybe even in the
family there's social rank um I have a
sibling I remember um who got more of a
of a piece of cake like even a slight
difference in that you know was
something that my older sibling would
point out um because she was more
effective at getting the slightly larger
piece of cake cuz I was until I was you
know big enough to offend for myself um
and my friends with larger sibling pools
in their family it was especially
competitive yeah I don't if you've ever
gone to a meal with somebody who had a
lot of siblings they eat fast they they
different resource allocation methods
than if they were an only child versus
uh one sibling MH they there's variation
here I'm generalizing but um but yeah
let's talk about social rank what do we
know about how social rank is organized
in the brain how we perceive our own
social ranking and um yeah like what's
the what's the modern science on this
stuff I find it fascinating um I'm not
scared of any topic well most any topic
and I think this is one that that
affects us all yeah I mean I'll first
say that social rank is something very
specific to a certain type of hierarchy
that assumes a linear hierarchy which
sometimes forms but oftentimes there's
different types of hierarchies that are
flatter or more Amorphis it's not really
clear who's who's the alpha on the
playground I don't know there's this
click here there you know it can be
dynamic right right it's Dynamic it's
not always organized as such but um if
you get animals into a sort of small
space um you will see in many species
especially with in the males um forming
a linear hierarchy and um um we wanted
to explore this and so I think one of
the biggest challenges with studying
social Rank and this is something we've
struggled with as well is how do you
control for the
individual identity versus the uh the
actual rank so what I mean by this is
let's say there's a
study that says um that you know neurons
in a certain brain region fire to
animals of different ranks according to
the rank fire most of the alpha less
less less less down to the rank you know
does that does that tell us that this
brain region encodes social rank maybe
in a loose sense and I'm sure that when
rank issues come up a lot of the brain
lights up for different comp different
reasons but for example let's say the
amydala would respond more to the Alpha
maybe because it inodes social rank but
maybe also
because whoever is the dominant is the
one who's most likely to have
consequences and so all of my
interactions with the alpha are
relatively High consequence and so I'm
sort of stressed out whenever I'm
talking about Alpha paying attention and
you know you remember all the
interactions you have with your boss
more so than you know someone else
there's an attention hierarchy
subordinates attend more to dominance
and so there's it's almost hard to make
this comparison because it's not all
flat like the the clean experiment which
we are still trying to do it's it's
difficult to do the perfect experiment
would be if you take an individual and
change their rank so for
example um I like to use this example
with Barack Obama so just indulge me I
know that this is from a while ago but
once upon a time I met Barack Obama for
a very brief moment when he was
president and and maybe there's some
neurons that light up oh wow you know
there's the Barack Obama president
neurons but if they are identity neurons
once he was no longer president if I was
to be presented with Barack Obama then
they would still fire if they were
ranked Neons then maybe after he was no
longer president it just these neurons
fire to whoever is president now and so
I think that experiment is very
difficult to do and has not been done
but we're working on it right now um in
uh uh another experiment where we take
animals and they're living in groups uh
and we rank them all and then we rehouse
them so everybody has a rank that they
start with then we put all the alphas
together put all the betas together Etc
so that everybody forms a new rank then
you have animals that went up a rank
went down a rank or stayed the same for
every group and so that's something that
we're looking at right now so initially
you take a pool of animals and then
let's say you got your number one two 3
four just for sake of Simplicity let's
say I take the number four lowest in
that hierarchy but now I make them the
top of a new hierarchy that's right
that's right got it and so it's really
preliminary and we'll see what happens
but we're
investigating it it seems that when you
take
Alpha's intermediates or subordinates
and put them together into new
hierarchies it takes them different
amounts of time and then Dynamics are
very different in forming the new
hierarchy and so in any kind of
predictable way that you're willing to
share or is it just too early I think
it's too early but I'll just say I guess
it seems like the
um the intermediates might be taking the
longest amount of time to form the
hierarchy they don't know where they sit
in the hierarchy they they were flexible
or something whereas the dominants
they're going to Duke it out and then
you know we're going to we're going to
battle there'll be defeat it's quick the
fight doesn't last that long
subordinates you know I I I you know we
have to still observe this is all still
you know being we'll see if everything
replicates but certainly the Dynamics
are different what the exact readouts we
you know we're working on what the
features are what key features to to see
but it's kind of uncanny because these
are genetically inbred animals that are
all hous in these should be all everyone
should be the same theoretically but
this makes me think that during certain
developmental periods rank is shaping
your long lasting development I think
it's a simple similar phenomenon perhaps
to the older child younger child
phenomenon where you know if you're the
oldest you go into the world and you
have lots of different roles you might
be the bottom you know you're going to
play on sports teams and be in different
classes and have all these but the the
the leadership desire slash potential
skill seems to be correlated in a very
non-scientific way you know the number
of presidents that's often old oldest or
only children this type of thing it's
it's a loose correlation there's a lot
of other reasons why it might not be
behavioral but there's sort of you know
fluffy fluffy correlations about that I
think there's something to it though um
when plasticity happening you're this
this becomes your most familiar state of
assuming a certain role and that
attractor state deepens with more time
spent there I find that so fascinating
I've also observed and I think I've seen
a few papers on I don't know how
rigorous these papers are that um
youngest or let's just say not oldest
siblings um here we're setting aside
single children that don't have any
siblings but that youngest siblings uh
do tend to quote unquote break the mold
more in terms of uh socio and cultural
norms of the family they they Venture
further in terms of um experiences and
systems they're often seen as having had
fewer constraints than the older sibling
which may or may not be true um but that
the youngest uh siblings often will um
take on risk yeah that older siblings
won't yeah yeah yeah and that's
certainly been my observation
nonconformists right I mean I'm a young
younger brother of an older sister um
but and then but then there was times in
our childhood where she was out of the
house and I was at home just with my mom
so so that sort of changes things but
and it's very Dynamic I realize we're
playing here in in a kind of a loose
space but but I find Social rank stuff
to be super interesting I grew up in a
big pack of mostly boys um that's just
kind of how it worked out in my
neighborhood um at the time um and it
was very interesting because it was very
clear it was a dynamic hierarchy where
if we were skateboarding certain kids
were Alpha if we were playing soccer
other kids were Alpha if we were doing
anything artistic um if it was uh kind
of geeky knowledge and and nerdy stuff
um you know then you know might have
been somebody else who had the knowledge
um and had the information that people
wanted so I think Dynamic hierarchies
are really interesting and I think um
get us out of that sort of more standard
Alpha like kind of chest beating telling
everyone what to do dictatorial model I
mean and this is now fully out of any
science land and into speculation
opinion land but I think that type of
structural structure where when you're
doing different tasks different
individuals become the the alpha or the
leader because it's based on competence
is very healthy I think structures where
you have locked down this is the this is
the hierarchy where someone's the boss
of you because of this one skill but
there's all these other skills that
they're not as they're they're not
Superior you know they they they don't
don't outrank you at and and so how do
you work all of that out and so I think
that's also something about keeping
score like what is what is the rank
right and so we did this experiment
where we designed a
task um animals are trained that a queue
predicts reward delivery only one animal
can get at a time it's just a very
narrow place so if one animal's getting
it you can't get it then um we would
have four animals that are CAG mates
four mice that are cagemates and we
would have two of them duke it out at
each point and they we know the ranks
the ranks are stable they have a rank
one two three four in the cage and
everybody does a round robin ones versus
twos ones versus threes two versus yeah
they well they they do round rabit in
this reward competition task they're
food deprived you know and we we present
rewards what's the what happens and so
subordinates do win some of the times
even though dominants win more all you
know they they consistently win more and
we found that prefrontal cortical
neurons you could represent very stably
and decode which animal was
dominant um flat regardless of the trial
and then when you looked at whether we
could decode competitive success meaning
who is going to win that next trial so
there's a new trial every 30 or 40
seconds and so but 30 seconds before
which is as far as we can measure
because then we're like kind of into the
previous trial as soon as the last trial
ends even before the next trial ends You
can predict above chance
significantly which animal is going to
win the next trial just based on the
firing pattern of prefrontal cortical
ter so you can predict winners and
losers you can predict
and understand where they are in the
hierarchy as well based on the ACT
activation of neurons prior to the
battle that's like recording from the um
by analogy it's like recording from the
prefrontal cortex of two let's say
business competitors or um martial arts
competitors and you can predict who's
going to win based on the pattern of
firing in their brains prior to the
competition that's right and so um that
suggests all sorts of things number one
it doesn't mean these competitions are
not independent there's something about
the state of the animal and when we
looked at is it just whoever won the
previous trial that did not account for
this and so um I thought this was really
interesting but when you look at the
decoding accuracy for dominants versus
subordinates about uh who will win the
next trial for dominance it stays pretty
flat it just has to do with I think this
is my speculation of our data um that
you know they they either are engaged or
they're not engaged the subordinates the
decoding accuracy is is above a it's
above chance but then it shoots up
somewhere around closer to the queue
presentation and so my speculation about
that is that the subordinates are
looking at the dominance they're looking
the dominant doesn't look like they're
it doesn't look like they're going to go
for it okay yeah there there looks like
they're turning away I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go so it's it's not like they're
both going out full every time it's it's
a calculation which trials oh he's not
paying attention you know it's like when
you're driving in traffic and you're
trying to find the the moment to cut
over and you're waiting for the person
who's like te texting and there just
there's a big space and everybody's just
getting in right here you know you can
just see you're like looking for clues
about the state of level you know of
competition and then and then the
dominants they are not looking at the
subordinate they're just doing whatever
they feel like doing it's like a there's
a I think there's that one scene in
Madmen where something happened in the
work environment and um and it was clear
someone's account didn't sell or
something didn't work out for one person
versus the other and I think one of the
characters says to uh Don Draper who's
clearly one of the alphas in that work
environment by virtue of yeah role and
and um position um says you know you
know I sometimes think about the way
that you blank blank blank and blank and
he goes on this brief tiate about how
upset he was and um and Draper says well
I don't think about you at all and then
the elevator I believe closes and it
really cemented his status in the office
as somebody who's really not paying much
attention to what other people are doing
he's just making decisions according to
what's going to be best for the firm and
in some cases for himself and in some
cases both so I think that's essentially
what you're talking about yeah I think
it's um it's kind of the nature of the
structure that's what makes you the
alpha is you're you you have you have
other things that are occupying your
attention and your your Visionary status
hopefully if you're you know a
productive successful Alpha and for a
sustainable you know group and then
everyone else is they don't they don't
need to have the big picture they don't
they don't you know it it becomes the
reinforcement schedule is different I'm
just looking for validation am I am I
playing my role okay it's a very
different mindset I think you know as a
scientist when you're a trainee
sometimes you're a a supporting member
on a team where you're getting
instruction someone's telling you what
to do versus the moment where you get
your own project and maybe you're
working by yourself maybe there's no one
to command but no one's telling you what
to do that is to me one of the biggest
thresholds to step over when you're
becoming a scientist or an investigator
is the first time where you just do
something and like try an experiment no
one told you to do and it feels super
weird it feels like you're sneaking
around or something and and then you
know I think I think
um in
today's mentorship chain sometimes that
that happens too late I think if we
could have that experience happen
earlier um I think that would only be
good
for for the future of research I agree I
was very fortunate that my graduate
adviser um told me look I'm going to
help you but I'm going to have two kids
while you're in the lab and I'm not
going to be around a lot so you're going
to have to figure it out don't burn the
lab down don't kill yourself with any of
the poisons in the lab and then my postt
talk adviser um the late and great Ben
Baris um largely treated the postto as
as Junior professor from an early stage
and I remember thinking he can't control
the experiments I'm going to do this is
up to me and he and and a great number
of us who were training with him at that
time went on to have our own lab so I
think um uh there's really something
important to that model and of course
we're discussing the research field but
um this could be exported to any number
of different fields because what those
mentors were essentially training us to
do was to um to assume the role that we
would eventually have as opposed to be
subordinates
um do you watch chimp
Empire so actually um just this week
yesterday and the day before before this
uh an postto interview who worked with
the chimps on chimp Empire visited an
interviewed him in my lab and um talked
about his work so I have not seen chimp
Empire but it's at the very top of my
to-do list oh God it's so good I don't
want to spend the next 20 minutes
talking about it but you see all sorts
of interesting um Behavior very relevant
human behavior hierarchies yes but also
um altruistic behavior um allopathic
grooming I mean in in chimp culture um
as I've learned from the show assuming
it's accurate um that who Grooms who is
very important um and there's all sorts
of interesting um Maneuvers that
subordinates make and there's all sorts
of interesting displays of vigor that
the alpha makes to remind people that
they are the alpha and then
as they age or make mistakes of judgment
the subordinates also will Fain
deference they'll be like oh yeah you're
the alpha you're really tough and
secretly they're plotting to replace the
alpha um so whether or not we're talking
about a scene from Mad Men or we're
talking about chimp Empire we're talking
about Research Laboratories or um or any
other landscape kindergarten I think
these circuits are active in all of us
and the sooner that we uh acknowledge
those and try and find um one that
generalize to the the goodness of as
many uh members as possible um we're not
doing our task but clearly you're doing
the task so okay social rank is
something that uh we need to acknowledge
no doubt um which actually leads me to
what might seem like a desperate topic
but um one that I know we're both very
interested in and that you're focusing
on now which is psychedelics because one
of the interesting things about
psychedelics is their capacity to
increase
neuroplasticity um but but also some of
the psychedelics and I realize MDMA is
not a classic psychedelic but they are
classified as empathogens they increase
empathy for self and others so uh what
are you looking into with psychedelics
which psychedelics and um yeah what
brought you to the study of psychedelics
and by the way I've done participated in
clinical because people will wonder I
have participated in clinical trials for
uh psilocybin and MDMA I don't recommend
people do psychedelics Recreation I do
think they hold great promise for the
treatment of depression and trauma but
people need to be careful there are
certain people who could not and should
not take psychedelics because it would
be genuinely unsafe for them um
psychologically especially young people
so there's my disclaimer and um but they
are fascinating compounds so um I guess
I've always been interested in
psychedelics I think I wrote my
undergraduate thesis about it's just
about hallucinations produced by
psychedelics psychotic breaks and REM
sleep and schizophrenia just comparing
what is the common thread when our brain
creates a reality that is not
objectively there and um psychedelics of
course is a way that we can experience
that and remember it and recall it in a
way that's very difficult with REM sleep
and and sometimes with psychotic breaks
um obviously schizophrenia is not
something that you can transiently give
yourself and have that experience so I
think having the ability to move into
other brain States is what makes it so
attractive I think the other component
is the the plasticity you can you can
have an experience and perhaps the
firsthand experience is you have an
epiphany that you take with you it's
life-changing and you know your life
habits are completely different for a
long lasting way after this singular
experience is is kind of one of the
things that makes it so different from
all of the other um therapeutic
treatments that we've got or most of the
other ones I'd say um and so for me you
know right now there's a lot of work
going
on exploring psychedelics as a therapy
for various different conditions disease
States um I think that's great I think
it's really important work I'm glad a
lot is being done on that I think my
focus
is is to turn over some rocks that might
not have been turned over yet and just
to get really down at a quantitative
rigorous mathematical level of what is a
hallucination for example um when I
asked this question what is a
hallucination I'm interested in the
actual cellular mechanisms are we just
you know we think about neurons having
signal to noise and neurom modulation as
changing that are we just changing the
signal to noise ratio and then pattern
completing all the noise and that's what
a Hallucination is we just you know take
that's we're just reinterpreting noise
and and putting sort of existing Maps
everything's fitting to existing mold or
map that we've already got that then
appears as some
hallucination um or is and and and you
know maybe it doesn't have to be
hallucination there's also obviously
some various different thresholds of the
Psychedelic experience um but all these
clinical statements this human
self-reported
um Quality ative descriptions of the
Psychedelic experience things like being
having just more positive outlook being
uh uniting one self and other like a
sort of you know Clarity of the world
um more labile in thoughts more flexible
thoughts uh we are trying to just
create actual ways to test them so for
example this idea about what is what is
going on in your mind when you when
you're having a psychedelic experience
all of these different states might feel
more labile um it maybe the transition
probabilities between different brain
states of like happy sad thinking
nostalgic you know maybe it's just all
looser and so you can access everything
because the transition probabilities are
just High another possibility is that
and maybe it's dose dependent at a
certain dose you go into another brain
State and so
previously we've done this in the same
project I was just about rank um we were
recording for prefontal cordal neurons
and looking at all the behaviors and so
the behaviors for representing social
rank we don't know what they are so we
used computer vision to extract a bunch
of Behavioral motifs and then tried to
understand what's the best model that
would predict you know what the animal
is going to do next not just wins and
losses but all the subtle gestures are
we going to fight are we going to give
it up are we going to back off and
predict the behaviors from prefrontal
cortical activity and the best model
that we found with something called a
hidden maravian model which essentially
just means that there are hidden States
you might think of them as moods um you
might give them some other name but I'll
I'll I'll use moods Loosely it's not
perfect but um that's kind of one way
that helps me think about hidden states
where you have certain statistics of
behaviors that you would produce if I'm
sad there's certain things I'm going to
do it's a different statistics and of
when I'm happy different probability of
going surfing if I'm sad or happy or you
know things like that so we basically
found that there are a certain number of
hidden States and so if you are on
psychedelics would that change the
number of states or just the transitions
between them we also found in our
prefrontal cortical representation that
there's a certain distance of the
representation of self and other in this
you know dimensionality reduced activity
space so for mumbo jumbo that just means
there's a representation of self and
other there's some quantifiable distance
in in
abstract you know terms in the brain and
we can quantify if those representations
get closer together and merge of self
versus other of self versus other so
that's something that we would want we
would be looking for if you are putting
psychedelics on these are these are
questions that I'm interested in that
are under construction so right now
we're recording from
um animals while we're giving them cybin
using neuropixels recordings so
recording from thousands of neurons um
in preal cortex and other parts of
Cortex cuz the you know the shank goes
to lots of places and looking at how um
animals respond in a conflict task so
there's there's trials where there's a
Quee that predicts reward a queue that
predicts shock then there's some trials
where both cues are presented and both
outcomes are presented and the reason
for this conflict trial is that actually
if you give you know moderate to low
doses of psilocybin or most drugs
honestly animals can do this
you know even on lots of different drugs
most people can still eat food and avoid
getting hit by this truck I mean there
are exceptions of course but generally
speaking you know there's a lot of
different brain states where you can
still do these these essential functions
pretty robustly but it's about what
happens in the more ambiguous Zone what
happens when there's a conflict and and
what do you do how do you when there
when it's a little gray I think that's
when you can see a shift in veilance
assignment so that's something that
we've been looking for and trying to see
if um you know in clinical studies
they're exploring set and setting um as
maybe the factors that have in the past
historically given very unpredictable
outcomes for psychedelic therapies um
it's possible that it's set in setting
it's also possible that there's
individual variability it's possible
that there are biomarkers that can
predict which individuals would be well
suited for this type of therapy and so
those are also things that we're
interested in I find this so fascinating
and I I just want to applaud you again
for taking on these hard questions these
are fairly high level questions um
certainly there's a lot of uh clinical
trials exploring psychedelics like
psilocybin and their role in treating
mental health um and there's at the same
time um a real dir of studies exploring
mechanistically how these compounds are
working I mean um I do want to tip my
hat to all the folks that have explored
dendritic changes and you know so
cellular changes in the level of neurons
and and on and on but in terms of these
like higher level states of um self
versus other recognition um in
psychedelics um you know that those are
tough questions that need to be
addressed mechanistically and it's clear
you're doing that um I I think this um
this notion that you're testing of
whether or not psychedelics reveal more
accessibility or liability as you
described it of between different states
like oh wow I can actually move from sad
to Happy there's a there's a route for
that and you can experience that as
opposed to just being told that hey when
you're feeling sad feel your you know
the field of psychology especially pop
psychology is in a real crisis right now
in my opinion because we're told to feel
our feelings but then we're also told to
not react to our feelings which sounds
great but if those feelings get intense
enough that's very hard for most people
to do so it's feel your feelings but
don't stay with you know what there's
the cathartic model you know like feel
your feelings and and get them out
screaming and Etc and then there's the
the no you know the more you engage a
neural pathway the stronger that neural
pathway gets and therefore you're just
going to feel more anger there's a lot
of conflict right now in terms of the
popular
psychology version of this whereas the
the clinical Fields I think have a an
understanding that hasn't been
translated I think one other thing about
psychedelics that is interesting is that
the transitions into States is also more
labile like if you start feeling a
little sad you know there's the
potential to feel very very sad and to
go into a state of sadness of of an
intensity you've never experienced
before which by the way could be
therapeutically beneficial um I think
there's some evidence for that provided
there's adequate support before during
and after those sessions
um but I think most people feel when
they're not on psychedelics will feel
emotions that are uncomfortable and
will'll do all sorts of things to try
and avoid those emotions so I I'm not
speaking as a clinician here but I just
again I think what the the uh the range
and specificity of questions that you're
asking about psychedelics I I find so
exciting another uh uh reason I'll say
that you we want to have you back to to
discuss those findings when that when
they come out let's talk a little bit
about you okay um I've known you for a
while but to be honest I think this is
the longest conversation we've ever had
which is one of the reasons I love doing
this podcast I get to sit down with
colleagues and have intellectual slash
other conversations of of substantial
depth that I wouldn't have the
opportunity to have
elsewhere I know enough about you
however to know that um you've been
involved in various things um I'm not
going to say peripheral to science but
you have other interests as well um as I
recall um you have been a yoga
instructor or a or you've been involved
in the uh kind of wellness fitness uh
Community industry tell us about that
and then I'm also curious about um how
you structure your day your routines
given that you're a parent of two young
children you run a very large laboratory
operating at the very highest level um
and of course you value important things
like relationships and relationship to
self and health and all these sorts of
things so um not to make it too
open-ended but yeah like tell us of tell
us of your interests and and of your
relationship to Wellness and fitness and
well-being yeah um I guess I
think you know I everybody comes to
their their calling in in some what
feels like a path that you could have
predict but when you look at it outside
I guess both of my parents are
professors so it doesn't look super
surprising that I'm a professor but
that's not how it felt to me when I was
in high school I was a total rebel I
just threw parties at my house my
parents weren't there sorry everybody
who's listening it's not I don't
recommend that but I just cared about I
just cared about having fun and sports
and
um I
think school wasn't maybe challenging
enough for me at that time I didn't
necessarily recognize that that was what
it was but um I've always enjoyed being
really active and that's what makes me
feel good it's I I I definitely um agree
with stuff you've said on your podcast
about having exercise routines in the
morning that really influence the rest
of your day I I didn't always exercise
in the morning at different phases but
um yeah after I was an undergrad I took
some time to travel around Australia
backpack around Australia live in some
very remote places spend some time
living in a tent then I was a yoga
instructor um then I I went to grad
school in the Bay Area I had a very
active uh hobby of I was a
semi-professional break dancer I was
very into break dancing really really
competitive break dancer in area yes we
did um you know halftime shows or I
guess technically third quarter timeout
shows at Oracle Stadium for the Golden
State Warriors I was the one girl who
could do a windmill so they would use me
okay windmills someone's going to find
footage of this yeah yeah there's some
you know very mediocre footage of me
break dancing um and I was just really
into it but I think that's where my work
life balance passion comes from I talk
about it a lot I think about it a lot
and people say to me all the time well
you is this really true why do you why
do you preach all this work life balance
stuff when you know you must have been a
workaholic at some point in your life
and I think you know when I was younger
I definitely didn't like the idea that
you had to only be one thing I wanted to
be so many things I couldn't decide it
was a huge challenge I was going to be a
writer I was going to be a yoga
instructor I was going to be I never
really thought I was going to be a
professional dancer I just wasn't good
enough and there's not careers to be
made from dancing really it's very
difficult but um you know had a lot of
other interests and I wanted to
prove I don't know who I wanted to prove
it to I think myself at first and then
eventually it made me May me feel like I
should maybe prove it to everyone that
you can have a very whole life and not
sacrifice everything you don't have to
choose between family and career or
personal life you can have them all you
just have to decide that it's a priority
and own that and make those choices on
on a daily basis and comes down to time
management and so it's been a very even
though it looks like oh K just likes to
have fun and have all these other
Hobbies it it's it's important because I
think that we need more role models in
especially in academic science where
people bring their whole selves to their
job and even though your job is a very
specific thing um because you have a
role as a mentor and you know I suppose
the mentor apprenticeship relationship
has evolved then there's I have you know
lots of comments about that too um in
Academia I still think ultimately when
when I was working in someone else's lab
and I definitely looked up to them they
were the role model obviously I'm
looking at yes there science I'm looking
at how they make this all work how you
how are you doing this how how do they
live their lives and how do they
approach balancing it all and so I guess
I just wanted to put some more data
points on the on the scoreboard where
people are having lots of hobbies and
other nonwork activities while still
making meaningful contributions and it
doesn't make you less of a less of a
scientist or less of a person because
you're a whole
human if anything perhaps it makes
people better scientists yeah did your
exploration of of yoga and or break
dancing inform anything about your your
research or was it really about
resetting uh your mind and body in
healthy ways so that you could return to
the lab feeling excited about returning
to the lab I think of always been of the
mindset where sometimes things don't go
well in a certain Arena and it's it
doesn't feel good to have all your eggs
in that
basket stuff goes wrong sometimes
experiment doesn't work sometimes you
find something out you lose a whole data
set it's you know bad news happens in
the lab and um I think just want to
diversify your portfolio so that your
happiness portfolio is not entirely
based on your accomplishments at work um
I think we just want to have more
elements and this the same thing goes
for you know at one point when I was
really into dancing I got a very serious
injury and it took this huge part of my
life away from me I was so glad I had
work thank God I have work you know I
have something I can do else and I just
think having a lot of different parts of
your life make you more flexible more
creative more awake more engaged and you
know when I don't I definitely have been
a workaholic when I was a postdoc and
assistant professor period definitely
did not make enough time for myself to
have a a richer a rich personal life at
certain points and very quickly I just
wither away into a shell of a human a
shell an empty shell of a the person I
used to be and it's noticeable everybody
can feel it you can't pretend you know
everyone that works with you feels it
eventually and so I think that's a big
thing and so as I've taken feedback from
my Anonymous lab surveys and other other
forms of feedback and just
reflecting it's clear I you know taking
your lifestyle into to and having agency
over designing your lifestyle to be
ideal for you is super important so a
typical day for me uh might look
like um okay the last work day let's say
I woke up actually so it was early high
tide so I got to wake up in the dark
pack up my bags go surfing and then get
home before surf see my friends in the
water and I think surfing is a lot of
things it's exercise it's it's a cold
plunge it's photons some of your
favorite things maybe a little bit
meditative maybe some social Community
then and I you know go every time at the
same day so there's the same group of
people then I go home make the kids
their snacks breakfast drop them off at
school then I go to a lab and then run
lab meeting um
and have meetings most of my day when
I'm at work is spent meeting with people
drawing on a whiteboard mostly meeting
meeting with my trainees um is what I
like to spend most of my time on of
course there's other stuff that gets in
the mix like administrative whatever and
then come home at a pretty early hour
pick up my kids make dinner and then go
to sleep kind of early kind of boring
these days that's my typical day sounds
exciting to me sounds exciting to me um
I think uh if one were to stay up late
then one feel sleep deprived if they
wake up early if you wake up late you're
missing out on the early morning Sunrise
the surf all of that I've never surfed
actually once I paddled out once when I
was in college and uh there was no surf
so I would paddle back in but um I keep
hearing about this surfing thing and um
people seem to love it that's one of my
concerns is that if you fall in love
with it you're going to spend a lot of
time out in the ocean but clearly it's
all serving you well and um uh must be
wonderful to be a child in your home I
can imagine how much fun it is and how
interesting it is um you mentioned
several
times uh mentorship and trainees and
it's clear that
uh reshaping um the landscape of science
for the Next Generation coming up is
something that's of real passion to you
um I take great uh pleasure in asking
this because um you know it wasn't long
ago that you and I were graduate
students in postdocs and more or less
the same vintage right and as is the
case people retire people die this is
the reality of life and people move up
up the ranks as you have um so what are
some of the things that you're most
passionate about in terms of shaping the
future of science um in particular
research science but maybe more broadly
and um what do you doing about it I
think that
um science academic culture has
evolved and and I guess I should start
by just saying first I as I was driving
over here it's just beautiful drive and
I'm just thinking it is so cool that we
get to do this for a living isn't it
amazing
that studying whatever I find
interesting to me is something that I
can you know have a secure job for and
then just thinking about cool ideas and
directions and talking about it stuff
that I would do for free is is really my
job and I I just am so grateful to have
that and um um I think there are a lot
of beautiful sides of Academia that
sometimes don't get the airtime that
they deserve and of course there's a lot
of Doom and Gloom there always has been
when I was a grad student there's lots
of Doom and Gloom in The Ether there's
plenty now um I think perhaps it has
become a little bit more dire um the
plight of Academia right now uh there's
been a nationwide drop of posts in
general there's just a mass Exodus away
from Academia to Industry and I think
that reflects the changing environment
and so um I guess when I was a graduate
student I had this book in my desk
drawer called advice for young
investigator written by ramonica Hall
which is a great book it's thin it's a
quick read it's got some whims Whimsical
anecdotes and some some some important
insights I think um also a lot of
misogyny very much glamorizing work
workaholic Tendencies and you there was
definitely a picture of a scientist this
was the way to succeed other options not
really offered and and I really
struggled with that I had a lot of
impostor syndrome coming up through I
mean I someone asked me when when did I
when did I stop having impostor syndrome
I think maybe
2021 you know very recently I think I
spent 20 years of my career having
impostor syndrome wondering if I was
good enough if I was going to make it am
I going to do I have what it takes and
constantly doub Ting and questioning it
um and I think that it would have been
nice to to not feel so alone at that
period of of my career um so I think
some of the things that were described
in this original book um were really
important for academic research to be
born as a thing like how do we make this
be a thing that you can get paid for you
know how do we make this be a job that
people get to have and then at this
point I think most people would agree we
need science science is important we
want to we want to we benefit from
science um and I think at this point
it's not so clear that we need elitism
as much as we did before it's not um
we're we're looking at a crumbling
academic culture where where we're
struggling to retain people and you know
that's it's not it's not a great
sustainable Dynamic I think trainees are
not getting compensated well enough or
treated treated well enough that it's an
attractive choice and so I think we need
sort of make a change and nothing wrong
necessarily about about the intentions
that were set hundreds of years ago but
things change and where where we are now
and things are changing very
quickly so um I I guess I get to make
one of my childhood dreams which is to
to write a book come true um in uh I get
in and one of the benefits of social
media I did have a tweet kind of you
know just sort of spontaneously ranting
about about how this book is problematic
and it's very
misogynistic and maybe we need another
book for other types of people um and
that makes people feel more
included um and so and and this tweet
went around and it s I didn't expect you
know I didn't expect anything to come to
this I'm just you know living my daily
life and then my DM suddenly had
literary agents and a book deal and then
okay I'm now I'm writing this book and
so I'm at about halfway
through but I think the the goal of the
book I I don't really have time for this
project to be honest but it's such an
important project to me um I think
that
I I want to see Academia be a one of the
healthiest places why is it second only
to the military in the pervasiveness of
sexual misconduct
and you know things yeah y did you know
that so actually you know factoid is
Academia is the military is worse in
terms of sexual misconduct retaliation
issues that occur but Academia second
and I and it makes you wonder what are
the parameters that
make this type of abuse so rampant I
think one of the obvious ones is the
clear ranks how stable the rank ranks
are how the power structure um of
Academia and the military veryy fixed
not super debatable not difficult to
move these the ranks are you know
they're there and the power structure is
very skewed and those are the
ingredients
that facilitate abuse and so I
think in the
military I could see a very good
argument for why that hierarch that
strict rigid hierarchical structure is
necessary there's not time for making
mistakes get it but with
Academia there's there's time there's we
what do we we're not you know it's not a
war we're we're just studying stuff that
we think is cool why is uh such a rigid
hierarchy with such devastating
consequences necessary I would argue
maybe it's not and um I think I've been
spending a lot of time thinking about
this for myself I've been um I I found
this professional leadership coach I I
love and just thinking about
sustainability how do we make an a
sustainable ecosystem and um it's not
something you find in a lot of
leadership management uh literature that
I that I've been exposed to so I'll take
I'll take a note from from the the
podcast and say if anyone knows of
literature that talks about developing
sustainable um ecosystems within
leadership and management I would love
to hear about that in the comments but
um I think that's a big hole um people
think about making things stable the
power structure should be stable but
actually being flexible and dynamic is
what gives systems resilience and and
flexibility um to to survive and right
now all the cracks in in the towers of
Academia are showing and it's time to to
see if this is are we going to adapt and
survive or are we going to the crumble
there's a lot to unpack there and I'm
grateful that you're drilling into all
of that with I'm sure the same rigor and
um attention to asking the really
critical questions that you have in your
lab um certainly I observe the landscape
changing very rapidly um I think there's
also a lot to be learned and to explore
that um exports to other professions I
certainly um believe that the more um
firsttime opportunities to experience
the beauty of doing research and biology
in particular because that's what I'm
familiar with um the more likely that we
are as a field of research and science
to make more fundamental discoveries in
other words the more people that get the
experience of trying science doing
exploratory research science the more
likely we are to pull from that pool and
within that pool there will be people of
competence uh talent and and also gifted
like we just you know sort of like
increase the the size of the net y um
and the net of course is netting
something very specific which is you and
I both know that um while training
certainly matters knowledge is important
um that ultimately you know love of
craft and passion um and just being
tickled by that research bug once that
neuron that you know gets tickled that
lets us see something for the first time
or know something
um down the microscope or in a in a data
plot or something there's there's really
no going back so I I you know I want to
be very clear that I loudly applaud your
efforts to extend the experience of
research to people and earlier you were
telling me that you're doing this that
many of the people in your lab are
firsttime researchers they didn't come
through the pedigree of research yeah I
know we do a lot of Outreach about 25%
of my lab this summer was firsttime
research experiences and so um we've
been really privileged to have the
bandwidth to support that um I will say
though I mean on the same tip I think
what you've done with this podcast is
incredible you've made millions of
people who didn't have access to science
or Neuroscience be fascinated with
neuroscience and now imagine what if
every person that listened to this
podcast and thought this is such a great
podcast I wish I could do some
Neuroscience could do it with some you
know not full-time what if they could
contribute in any just whatever level
that they wanted to that's so much more
contribution that we're currently
missing out on because there's so many
barriers to be able to contribute to
science and I think um removing the ones
that are really there as well as the
ones that are just perceived to be there
is so powerful but I mean the podcast is
a a you know proof the proof is in the
pudding the proof is in this podcast how
many people could fall in love with
science if they were given a chance to M
well thank you for that it is indeed a
labor of love for me and um and there
are opportunities maybe we'll provide a
link to a couple of them um where uh
certain projects in Neuroscience are
crowdsourcing data analysis is actually
quite fun there's the connectone project
where you can trace neurons it's
actually very very pleasing you can do
it while listening to podcast or a book
kids can do it you're you're tracing
these neurons basically filling in lines
it's like a coloring book and you're
contributing to the parcelation of
understanding the structure of of the
brain including the human brain and
without that crowd sourcing um it's just
not going to happen I mean there efforts
to make machine learning do it and to do
it through AI but that there's a lot to
be gained from having actual humans do
this that those Technologies don't quite
yet approximate so we'll provide a link
to to some of those projects but listen
K Dr Tai of course um I want to thank
you so much first of all for coming here
today and sharing so much knowledge and
also being willing to go into some
places that were um by virtue of my
questions a little speculative and and
and really think about those and and and
address those through the lens of of
deep mechanistic understanding of how
these circuits work and to make it clear
to people um your enthusiasm for science
is infectious in the most positive sense
of the word and I know that so many
people are going to benefit from from
your knowledge and also from the work
that you've been doing in your
laboratory you know I've seen your star
rise and it's um still going going going
and it's just remarkable and
extraordinary but I must say not at all
surprising so um that and your advocacy
work and for all you do and that you're
doing um I just on behalf of myself and
everyone listening I just want to extend
a genuine and really heartfelt thanks
thank you thank you so much and it's
been such an honor to be on the Hub Lab
podcast it's legendary so thank you so
much for having me absolutely we'll do
it again thank you for joining me for
today's discussion all about the biology
of social interactions with Dr K taii to
learn more about her work and to follow
her on social media please see the links
in the show note captions if you're
learning from Andor enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's a terrific zeroc cost way
to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on both Spotify
and apple and on both Spotify and apple
you can leave us up to a five-star
review please check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast if you
have questions or comments about the
podcast or topics or guests that you'd
like to suggest for the hubman Lab
podcast please put those in the comment
section on YouTube I do read all the
comments not so much on today's episode
but on many previous episodes of The
hubman Lab podcast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like improving sleep for
improving hormone function and for
improving Focus to learn more about the
supplements discussed on the huberman
Lab podcast visit Liv momentus spelled
ous so that's Liv mous.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media I am hubman lab on
all social media platforms so that's
Instagram Twitter now called X Linkin
Facebook and threads and on all those
platforms I discuss science and science
related tools some of which overlaps
with the content of the hubman Lab
podcast but much of which is distinct
from the content covered on the hubman
Lab podcast again that's huberman lab on
all social media platforms if you
haven't already subscribed to our
monthly neural network newsletter our
neural network newsletter is a zeroc
cost newsletter that includes podcast
summaries and protocols as short 1 to
three-page PDFs for instance we have
zeroc cost protocols for improving sleep
for improving dopamine function for
deliberate cold exposure for Fitness for
Learning and neuroplasticity and much
more to sign up for the newsletter
simply go to hubman lab.com go to the
menu tab scroll down to newsletter and
supply your email again the newsletter
is completely zero cost and I want to
emphasize that we do not share your
email with anybody thank you once again
for joining me for today's discussion
with Dr Kay Tai and last but certainly
not least thank you for your interest in
[Music]
science